I don't, I'm not talking to you until we're recording.
(Adam chuckling)
Too much talking before the podcast.
(bright upbeat music)
Hey everybody, welcome or welcome back to Roll On,
where Mr. Adam Skolnick and I are back
in the lime green chairs
to banter across this absurdly long table.
What are we gonna do today, Adam?
You know what?
Before we even get into anything,
I'm gonna say straight up, I'm under-prepared for today.
You are?
Yeah, it's an experiment.
Well, I've over-prepared.
I think I've generally over-prepared for these Roll On's,
and then I end up looking at my iPad the whole time,
instead of making eye contact with you.
Let's do a segment where we just,
it's called "Uncomfortable Eye Contact" and we just
Oh, I'm an expert at that.
We just can't look away.
It's called "The Uncomfortable"
This will create an exceptional listener experience.
Yes.
You don't have to speak, you just look at each other.
Yeah, great pod.
Great pod! (laughing loudly)
Good, awesome, dude.
What are we gonna do today?
Well, we're gonna celebrate a couple milestones.
Yeah.
Probably get a little bit random here and there.
Less focus on newsy-type stuff.
That was the result of a creative meeting we had.
We'll see how that goes.
Is that real?
More on like
Well, I'm the executive producer here.
You are, you are.
So I'm making that executive decision.
You call the shots.
Yeah, I don't know, like do people really want us
delving into the headlines?
Some people do.
Maybe, some.
Is some enough?
I think more on the life lesson-y type show.
I like that.
That's what we're gonna focus on today.
Of course, we're gonna answer a few listener questions,
and then call it a day, bro.
Nice.
It's raining out
and we have other stuff to do.
(Adam chuckles)
You might.
Yeah, well you got a few things going on.
I do, I do.
Why don't you check in?
But actually before you do that
Yeah.
I wanna make a little bit of a request or an ask
to the listeners and the viewers.
For long-time fans of the show,
you know that last year around the holiday season,
we did this special episode around listener stories,
where people called in,
they shared their experience of the podcast,
how it has sort of benefited their lives,
and some storytelling around that,
and so we're gonna reprise that episode.
It was really special, it was very cool,
and if you would like your experience or your story
considered for inclusion in this episode,
leave us an extended voicemail at 805-421-0057.
That's 805-421-0057.
Last year, this was really meaningful to us,
and I think also to you guys, the audience.
Everybody who listened and reached out
seemed to really enjoy it, so we're excited to do it again.
We've already gotten a huge response,
but obviously, we can always use more.
So if you missed it last time,
because we haven't been doing that many Roll On's,
get on it.
So last time, and I'll include this
in the show notes as well, of course,
the number is 805-421-0057.
Love it.
Yeah, man.
So how you doing, what's happening?
Well, I've just started my new business.
It's not launching just yet,
because, obviously, we just hit this inclement weather
season is upon us, but we're excited
to debut it next spring.
It's drizzling out. It's drizzling and 65.
Oh, yeah.
Sorry.
It's my new Instagram picnic collab with LeBron James.
Okay.
Yeah. LeBron and I
have been working on our driftwood shelters
and our wildflower wreaths,
and we're gonna have romantic picnics
available for anybody who wants to, you know,
pay the price tag.
Right, to join the two of you?
No, we're the ones that put on, we cater.
He's quite the patisserie.
I mean, I don't know if you knew that or not.
I'm sure there's a joke in here somewhere that I don't get
cause maybe I don't follow basketball enough, but.
No, no, no.
Explain.
You know, these picnic collabs.
Don't you see these
No.
Don't you see these Instagram picnics around the beaches?
You've never seen one?
I'm 56 years old, Adam.
I am not in that like silo of Instagram or whatever.
All right, my warm opening fell flat.
There's a weird thing
where like people share picnic photos?
Like, I'm confused.
Yes. There's romantic, there's a thing.
It's a pandemic business that popped up
and there are these, there's Instagram picnics,
like you pay and someone has created a habitat for you
to enjoy like a nice romantic meal on the beach.
Uh-huh.
And then you take the photos,
and you're like sipping whatever and eating your fine food,
and it's catered.
Do they take the photos
of you for you?
I don't know, I haven't gotten that far.
Does that include uploading them for you as well?
I think you probably upload yourself.
And where does LeBron come into this?
I don't understand.
I pitched him the idea
and he was over at Ben and Jerry's the other day.
Right, dropping in.
Yeah.
And so while I was there, I just,
he thought that I had a genius idea,
and you know, he's a businessman, so.
Right.
I pitched him.
Yeah, I don't know. I don't know.
I'm hoping to get him.
I might be premature for announcing.
Maybe table this one for now.
You don't like this one?
Yeah, no.
All right.
(both chuckling)
Go back to scooping the cream.
That's it.
You can indulge the dream.
That dream is not the dream.
I'm a lifetime scooper.
But with your feet firmly planted on the ground
Yes.
And back to a three-dimensional reality.
You do actually have some pretty exciting news.
I do, I do.
So on December 6th,
the sequel to David Goggins' "Can't Hurt Me"
his second book is launching.
It's called "Never Finished"
and it is finally finished.
There were times there
where we wondered if "Never Finished."
There's a little irony in there.
For a while, we worked really hard on it, man.
We've been working on it for,
we worked on it for about a year and a half,
and then obviously, it encapsulates not just this,
but the last four years, how he's, you know,
his life over the last four years plus stories and episodes
from his past life.
So in that way, it's almost like Shades of Sedaris
at this point. Like, or Sedaris, I should say.
David Sedaris?
Sedaris, yeah.
Yeah.
And you know how he can unpack his life and, and
Right.
And deliver it. David is.
The comparison ends there though.
Like, I can't think of two people less alike than
David Sedaris and David Goggins.
But in a way they aren't,
because I don't know if you knew this about David Sedaris,
he is like a psycho with his steps and he walks.
He collects trash for eight hours a day.
Yeah. 30,000 steps.
That I knew.
Yeah. So, but well my point is,
is that he's got this corner of the literary world now
that is really about, it's his memoir,
it's his life that he can continually unpack
and shape and entertain as well as educate.
Right.
Readers. And so that, and listeners,
and so it's kind of like,
I'm just trying to figure out how you compare it,
because there's nobody that's doing that,
and so it's like shades of that,
and also meets kind of "The Last American Samurai"
kind of book of philosophy.
It's like Goggins' graduate school.
So if you loved "Can't Hurt Me,"
this is like his true philosophy.
He, that's how he describes it.
"Can't Hurt Me" is like rocky.
This is kind of like how he actually does it.
Right.
And it's the same kind of concept.
It's like, it's stories from his life in chapters.
That's the main story.
And you know, how he's dealt with the ups and downs
the last four years and where he's going.
And I think people would be very surprised and impressed.
And then, in between that,
instead of challenges, there's evolutions,
and so it's all about kind of evolving
and these life lessons that he's learned throughout his life
and kind of uses today.
So that's it.
It's, the audiobook, once again is inter,
we do the chapter, we do an evolution,
we talk, unpack it further.
Right.
And do you read the chapters like you did last time?
I am the narrator in the chapters
and then we talk in between.
Goggins has some, a bit of narration as well,
and then it's just incredible.
So all of that's happening. It's spectacular.
Really honored to have been a part of it.
We're really excited about it,
and so we'll see what happens.
We got some competition in Prince Harry.
(Adam laughing)
Yeah.
And Michelle Obama again. But we'll see about that.
Oh, is Michelle Obama coming out with a book again?
She is.
At the same time that.
Three weeks earlier
Wow.
Again.
Tat-a-tat with Michelle once again.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Very interesting.
Well, I know that you've been working on this book
very hard for a very long time
and we've been cagey about it on the show.
You'd come in and you'd say,
"Well, I'm deep in this project"
but you wouldn't, you couldn't really talk
about what it was.
So, you know, obviously you've shared a little bit more
with me about what you've been doing behind the scenes,
and this is certainly a long time coming.
Super exciting.
Clearly there's a massive audience who is anticipating,
you know, what this next book is gonna be.
I did see David's announcement on Instagram
where he published that little video
and he told this story about, you know,
how people's second books usually suck
or that's what he was told.
Yeah.
And how he shared this book with some trusted advisors
and friends, and they were all amazed
that this one is actually better than the second one.
The first one was sort of a teaser.
He was playing it a little bit on the surface,
because he didn't want to go too far
because people might not be able to handle.
Right.
Like the full 100% Goggins.
And once he realized like,
"Oh, I tested this, there is an audience and an appetite
for what I have to say."
Now, he can go deep and is seemingly very encouraged
by this book that you guys worked hand-in-hand on.
Yeah.
And that is crazy exciting, so
You know, soon he's gonna be everywhere.
I'm sure.
Yeah.
You know, and it's like, you know,
also, let's not forget, once again, self-publishing, right?
Like he.
Yeah. Self-publishing.
They should be teaching his model
at Harvard Business School,
like what he's done as a self-published author
is completely unprecedented.
We think,
I mean, the words I've heard is that in nonfiction,
it's the biggest self-published book ever.
I'm not sure if that's true, cause I don't, haven't looked.
Four million?
Yeah, over four million now. It's like going
towards four and a half.
And does that include audio or does that just?
That includes everything, that includes audio.
And what is the percent I would,
I would think audio might be like.
It's over half.
It's probably usually like 40, but it's gonna,
it's gotta be over half at this point.
Yeah, I think it's,
I think I don't exactly have the number.
I think it's like 60, I'm pretty sure.
Right.
And, but that, you know,
he's been a product of the audio space, you know,
like that's like in terms of how he kind of got his fan
base, I mean, that's how it happened.
So it's not surprising.
I think, you know,
he set the standard to try to exceed "Can't Hurt Me."
Not in terms of sales,
but just in terms of quality of the book.
You know, it's never been about sales,
because if he wanted to do sales,
he could have put a book out two years ago,
and it, you know, it's never been about that.
It's about delivering something to the reader
and having the reader in mind and having something,
you know, it's very much about thinking
of how the reader is going to come out of the experience
of this book, and I think that's special.
You know, and it's challenging,
and when he first said, you know,
he wants it to be better than "Can't Hurt Me,"
I thought, "Wow."
I mean, I didn't think that was a reasonable goal,
to be honest with you.
Yeah.
But, you know, he's not about reasonable goals.
No, he certainly isn't.
And he tends to exceed the unreasonable goals, so.
Yeah.
So I believe.
But that must have been daunting from your perspective
entering into that with that objective.
Well, it was to, you know, look, so the way I,
I try to make writing as easy as possible for me.
So I don't think, I try not to actually think
about the end game because all I can do is the process of it
and make it the best it can possibly be.
I didn't think we'd get there,
But now there, I mean it's,
we'll see how people respond to it.
I love this book.
You know, it was, there was so much love put into it
when you, when people, I can't wait to talk about it more
like when the book is out and we can talk about it more,
but like, what he has done and achieved
some of the most incredible athletic accomplishments
I've ever heard of,
how he's dedicated his life and in the direction it is now,
I think it's gonna surprise a lot of people,
and it's just another level, and you know,
there's lessons on leadership,
there's lessons on day-to-day living,
there's lessons on how to kind of overcome obstacles
from being at the bottom of the barrel.
Of course, there's darker stories than,
I think, even some are darker than you've heard
in "Can't Hurt Me."
So just to be a part of it,
obviously was a thrill for me,
and I learned a lot of it, a lot from it,
and I can say I feel like I'm a better writer
for having done it.
So all of those things make me really excited to share this.
Yeah, Yeah.
Super exciting man.
Yeah, thank you.
I'm proud of you. It's great.
I'm excited for you. I'm excited for David.
Thank you.
And you know, it's a powerful message
that clearly resonates with a lot of people
and needs to be more broadly, you know,
like amplified to the culture.
No doubt. No doubt. No doubt.
I mean, I think that the lessons in here,
you remember like the last four years,
so we're talking about the pandemic,
we're talking about, you know, XYZ.
So like a lot, a lot.
You know, we're not, we don't dwell
on any one thing like that,
but there is, you know, Goggins will explain
how he dealt with it in his own way.
Yeah. Yeah. Cool man.
So again, the date that it comes out is December.
December 6th.
So we'll put a link in the show notes.
Pre-order it, all that kinda stuff.
Yeah. Thank you. Thank you.
Yeah, we're excited and look forward to hearing
how people respond to it and thank you
to all the Goggins fans and Rich Roll fans
who are on the train with us.
Yeah, cool.
You got recognized up in Big Sur.
It happens every once in a while. (Adam laughing)
I love that when that happens for you.
Yeah. Thanks man.
It's fun. I dunno how to hand,
I don't know where to put my hands.
You don't know where to.
I keep them to myself.
Put them on the phone for the selfie.
That's it, selfie.
There you go, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right buddy.
How are you man? What's going on?
I know you were at the Formula,
you were in the pits at the F1?
Yeah, I had an exciting experience in Austin
a couple weeks ago.
There's a lot going on.
Julie's in Egypt right now.
I think she's got another five days there.
She's been gone like two weeks or something,
like almost two weeks.
She's hosting a retreat there
and is having an amazing experience,
but, so I'm kind of at home with all the kids
and being a homebody at the moment,
but I did take Tyler and Trapper, the boys,
to Austin for our first inaugural Formula One experience
at the Austin GP.
Was it like happy birthday to me type trip
kind of thing?
Yeah, it was my birthday.
Right.
So we flew on my birthday, which was October 20th.
I turned 56.
Happy Birthday.
Got some thoughts on that as well.
And I thought a little boys trip could be fun.
The boys are super fans.
I had always found Formula One to be
kind of an impenetrable, you know, sort of sport.
Right?
Like I knew about Schumacher
and how he got paid a lot of money
and clearly this is a big deal in Europe,
but to me it was sort of like football, soccer,
you know, like I didn't really know that much about it
other than that there was a massive fan base
and those people are extremely passionate about it.
Yes.
And then "Drive to Survive" the Netflix series occurred
and I was all in on that,
like I found that series to be incredibly captivating
and created this emotional connectivity
with all of the different characters
and it gave me just enough information
to understand on a very base level what was occurring.
It's very surface level, that series, but they do.
Is that how the boys got into it?
Like by watching that series?
They were already kind of into it
and that kind of deepened the connection,
but they're so into it now,
they subscribe to the streaming service
and they get up in the middle of the night
to watch the races that are in Europe.
Like they follow it very intensely.
Much more so than me.
Right.
But I'm up to speed enough where I'm,
I would consider myself a fan
and I thought it would be really fun,
so we went and we bought general admission tickets,
but I knew a few people and I was like,
I don't know if we can, what we can kind of,
you know, finagle here,
but I've had sort of an internet friendship
with Angela Cullen, who's Lewis Hamilton's performance coach
for a number of years,
and she invited us to come to the paddock on Friday,
which is practice day,
and she got us into the Mercedes garage and gave us a tour,
which was like unbelievable.
Amazing.
We met Lewis briefly,
got to check out engineering
and really observe the mechanics
and the engineers and how they work together.
Got to meet Toto Wolff, who's the team director.
Met Lewis very briefly.
Brad Pitt was around with Jerry Bruckheimer.
They're having meetings about the Formula One movie.
Like it was crazy.
When is that happening?
They're gonna be shooting it next year
and they're gonna be shooting parts of it at the races.
I think next year there's gonna be a race in Las Vegas
and they're gonna shoot at that race.
So that was cool.
Like Lewis Hamilton is a producer on that movie.
Tim Cook was at the race because Apple TV
is financing the project.
So there's a lot of like interesting characters
walking around, and once you're kind of in the paddock,
it's sort of this VIP kind of red carpet experience
where you can mingle around and, you know,
the garages are all in a line
and they have hospitality suites on the opposite side
of each of the garages,
and people are just kind of going in and out
out of these all day,
including journalists and team directors,
and you know, drivers and crew and all that kind of stuff,
and it was just amazing to be a fly on the wall
and observe all of that.
Yeah.
And to be privileged enough to be in the garage and kind of
not only watch them assembling the car and like, you know,
taking the undercarriage off and putting it back on
and having somebody to explain to us why that's important
and what goes into the science and the engineering of that,
and then to have, Angela gave us headphones
and we were able to hear the drivers
communicating with engineering,
giving feedback while they were doing practice labs,
which was like crazy.
Amazing.
It's like the amount of science, engineering, teamwork,
communication that goes into Formula One is like beyond,
and then, shout out to my new friend Sean Doss,
who is an endurance athlete who's coached by Chris Howell.
He ran Marathon des Sables and is a sport agent.
He's a sports agent out of London and one of his big clients
is F1 and he's in charge of this hospitality experience
that they are curating and creating at Formula One,
and he was able to get us paddock passes
on Saturday and Sunday to watch the race
and kind of co-mingle around,
You know people.
what was going on there,
and like, well he was a new friend.
Like we went in expecting nothing
and we ended up with like the most privileged experience
you could possibly imagine.
Rad birthday.
Which is pretty cool.
And it was fun to see some other friends there.
Dan Churchill was there, who's a podcaster.
A friend of mine, New York City restaurateur
has a restaurant called Charlie Street,
and he was doing some food and beverage stuff
for Sean at that hospitality suite.
And Mike Gervais was there.
It was cool to see him, some other folks,
and just really kind of enjoy the race
from a beginner's mind perspective.
And it, like sort of reflecting upon that experience,
there's some interesting kind of takeaways
other than just like me sharing this fun birthday weekend.
It left me thinking a lot about the genius myth,
and the genius myth is something that I've
also been thinking a lot about because I just saw
the movie "Tar," which is all about the genius myth.
I don't wanna spoil that movie.
It's certainly an Oscar-contending motion picture.
Please go check it out if you haven't seen it already.
It stars Cate Blanchett as this heralded maestro,
this conductor, like the greatest music conductor,
living music conductor who's very celebrated
conducting the Berlin Symphony,
and it's a story about her life.
Fictional character, but it really upends this genius myth
in that we as a country sort of like to
hoist up these incredible high performers
and delude ourselves into believing
that they are outliers that are able to kind of
do what they do in isolation, right?
And the truth of the matter is,
whether you're conducting a symphony
or you're driving a Formula One car,
you are supported by gigantic teams of people
who work very diligently and hard
to make you look like a genius.
And when you're in the garage of Formula One
and you just see dozens and dozens of people,
and then you're in engineering
and all these people on laptops running diagnostics,
and the hundreds of people who are back at the headquarters
for the team who are working on the car
and improving the car and communicating with the engineers
and the mechanics, like it's insane how many cooks
are in that kitchen and the kind of flow of communication
that is required in order for that driver to sit in that car
and perform at the highest level.
We all see the pits where they come in and the pit crews
who operate so flawlessly and sort of magnificently,
but behind them are all these other people
who are kind of doing the same thing
in a way that's a little bit less sexy or romantic.
Or accessible.
Yeah. Accessible, right?
Yeah. And I was like able to watch this and I was like,
my head was exploding, right?
Yeah, yeah.
And then seeing "Tar"
and it's really about the same thing,
like all of these wonderful symphony musicians
that support the conductor and make the conductor look good,
and all the behind the scenes kind of stuff that goes into,
you know, creating the quote unquote genius,
and then the kind of narrative spooling that
the quote unquote genius does themselves to brand build.
Right, right.
And create that idea that they are a genius,
and then to kind of upend that
and deconstruct that and realize like,
it's not to say that there aren't extremely talented,
gifted people, but nobody excels or,
you know, sort of excels at the highest level,
at the elite level, in anything
without an unbelievable foundation of support
from lots of people who are not in the spotlight.
And that goes for this podcast and everything
that I've achieved, I think you would probably concur.
So I've just been thinking, you know,
kind of a lot about that subject matter.
There's no doubt about that.
Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, it's, you know, we're all,
the interconnection just doesn't go away, you know,
even if you're involved in a project of like sitting,
you're writing and you're tapping away,
even if it's a project of my own, it's, you're still,
you're still dependent,
even if you're just reporting a story from your,
you're dependent on sources, you're dependent on editors,
you're dependent on an operation that keeps a,
you know, a publication alive, you know?
Yeah. You're always just tapping into some sort of
part of the interconnected matrix in some way.
And now, you know,
in some places you can see it much more easily.
I mean, the fact that the conductors are like
considered the genius is pretty funny in that
because they're not actually playing the music
and like, you know.
But they're interpreting the music.
They're interpreting it, right.
They're making choices about how that music is expressed.
And they're arranging, and they're arranging.
Yeah. And they're seeing things you don't necessarily see.
So you need those kinds of soothsayers.
I mean, we have them,
we have kind of the curse of the genius now,
like we're seeing the dark side of genius.
A little bit.
Is kind of our era now.
Yeah. A little, there's a little bit of that.
I don't want to go down that
No.
sewage drain hole at the moment.
[Adam Laughing]
But I will say that I think there's something inherently
American about the whole idea as well,
because this is a country that's built on this notion
of rugged individualism.
Right.
And we prioritize individual success and excellence over,
you know, the kind of collective, you know,
the collective success of the whole.
Right?
And we love those stories,
and even if we can poke holes in them and say,
"Yeah, well that person did that"
but like if you take, you know, like we could take Elon Musk
and say, "Well, he's a self-made man"
but if you really rigorously analyze that,
you do realize that it is a myth in many ways.
Like he had help from lots of people
and some of the stuff about the way that, you know,
Tesla came to get, he wasn't a founder of Tesla.
Like, there's a lot of things about that where you realize
like, oh, he has worked with teams of people
and benefited from that and has been a, you know,
a builder of teams or whatever,
but the idea that, the sole genius idea
is never, you know, truly meets rough scrutiny,
like hard scrutiny.
Right, right.
The idea of the rugged, individualist boot-strapper,
you know, you have the vision,
you could make it happen kind of thing.
But in America we love that
and we don't want to hear differently.
We love, it's almost like it's part of the fabric,
and it came out of
maybe,
I don't know, the birth of the country where people,
the first settlers who moved here were like,
felt kind of cloistered and there was too many laws
and too much law and order in England
and a king and tells you what to do
and here you can just
Yeah.
Invisualize it.
Go do it.
If you wanna do it, do it.
And that lasted, of course,
that was never a hundred percent true
because there were people
that were enslaved here pretty quickly.
Yeah.
And then there were Native American people
who were here that didn't get quite a voice
to do with as they wanted.
But this notion of manifest destiny
and the kind of, you know, Mark Twain idea of like
lighting out on the frontier
Right.
And all of that
That survives.
It's like inherently American.
Yeah, yeah. And because of that, I think that's in there.
And there is a, you know, there is,
that goes to why we're so obsessed with kind of like,
people are obsessed with individual freedoms.
Why like some people were really offended by the mask thing
or the vaccine recommendation. Other people were.
Any inroad on individual liberty
is seen as a transgression.
Right.
And it's not responsibly calibrated against our
responsibility to the collective.
Right.
Like I talked about this
with Ryan Holiday on the podcast and I shared a reel,
where he articulated that notion very concisely,
and it was met with, not derision,
but I would say controversy,
like people don't like to hear that.
But you know, your liberty is only as valuable
as the responsibility with which
it's sort of packed in with, right?
Right.
Like.
Well April says it all the time coming from Australia
where there is a sense of collectivity.
That doesn't mean that there aren't people who chafe against
restrictions and aren't interested in individual freedom
anywhere. I mean, there is people
rebelling against restrictions.
Well, historically we've had that,
like during periods of duress, you know, for this country,
whether it's World War II or whatever,
where we've endured, you know,
a kind of a communal stressful experience for the nation,
we've been able to cohere and come together
and recognize that level of shared responsibility
to each other, but that seems to be
like something bygone like I'm not sure
that we could recapture that.
Well, I mean, but there,
like if you go to Australia and you rent a car
and just cruise around,
you'll notice if you're the American,
you're the one speeding.
Like there's things, like there's rules that are adhered to
in a much more kind of communal way than we have here.
I'm not saying that's better or worse,
I'm just pointing it out.
And so like, so she sees that, like
people speeding or breaking the driving rules,
like we just take that as
"Okay, yeah, why not go a little faster? It's fine."
It's not that way there.
People are just more ingrained to the collective over there.
That's just the way it is in the majority.
Right.
And it's interesting, I was thinking, you know,
same thing with people who are interested.
You know, I saw Teddy McDonald the other day.
He's now spending a, you know, his family's moved to Austin.
Right.
He comes back and forth and he was saying, he talked,
he met up with someone who's from San Diego
and was so loving Texas because you can open carry there.
And I thought a good solution to the open carry,
I'm not saying you shouldn't open carry
if you wanna open carry and that's your state,
what I'm saying is you have to commute by horse.
Well, if you're a strict constructionist, Adam.
They'd be commuting horse.
That would be construed as an impediment on your,
the expression of your right to bear arms.
What about spurs?
Can they wear Spurs in their Honda Civic
so that when they get out, I just wanna hear 'em coming.
Can they or do they have to?
They have to.
Yeah. I don't know.
No, it's not gonna work.
We're not going there?
I gotta see "Tar."
It's at the top of my list.
I think Kate Blanchett is
"Tar" is amazing.
Like, right. She's the top of the game.
She's gonna win the Oscar for that movie.
Like her performance is just luminescent.
As always.
It's quite an extraordinary movie.
It's probably different than what you might expect.
I don't know what people thought going into it.
It's a cancel culture movie, isn't it?
Well there's an aspect of that.
I wouldn't say it's a movie about cancel culture.
Okay.
There is, you know,
sort of a component to the narrative that entails,
you know, that that kind of experience.
I don't wanna spoil it, you know that.
But the other movie I would recommend,
and I don't know why I'm recommending it
because I haven't seen it yet. (Rich laughing)
That's what we do in the internet!
But I know, cause I've done some reading around it.
This is bad, right?
I'm gonna like talk about a movie I haven't seen.
This goes right into a future subject.
I'm only gonna say positive things though.
" Banshees of Inisherin" which I know you're excited to see.
I'm very excited.
I mean, like, who doesn't love McDonagh?
Like, this guy's a genius.
If you've seen "In Bruges"
I know that's one of your favorite movies ever.
"In Bruges" yeah.
He's pairing these two guys again together.
Colin Farrell, and what's his name again?
Is it?
Colm? No, not Colm.
No, not Colm.
No.
Look that up, somebody, on IMBD.
Yeah. And then we'll cut it in.
Yeah, exactly.
I feel terrible. I can't remember his name.
But anyway, like I do know,
and I don't wanna spoil this even though I haven't seen it,
I know that one of the themes is
it's basically about a fractured lifelong friendship
where one guy is sort of a happy go lucky dude
played by Colin Farrell and the other gentleman.
Brendan Gleason.
Brendan Gleason, Yes. Thank you.
Has decided that he wants his life to be about something
more meaningful and can't hang out with Colin anymore
and he's gonna devote his life to his art.
Right.
Which is music, right?
And so it's, the theme
being like the split within all of us
about what it means to live a good life.
Like what is a life well lived?
Is a life well lived one that is devoted completely?
Like I'm sure McDonough struggles with this in his own mind.
Like should I just devote myself to my work and my legacy
and these plays and these movies
and these screenplays that will live beyond me
after I die and just put all of my best energy into that?
Or should I be the guy who goes to the pub
at two o'clock every day and has a laugh with his buddies
and goes home, like feeling connected to his community?
Like what is, like if you're just going to, you know,
create a binary around those two things.
Right. Right.
Where do you devote your time and your energy?
And this is a movie that I believe, from what I understand,
grapples with this and, you know,
is about that struggle that I think is very relatable.
We all think about that sometimes.
Should I just look, if you think
like life is relatively meaningless,
then you should just fuck off and try to have as much fun
as possible
Right.
and not stress about too much.
Well.
Or if you take yourself seriously
or you're buying into this genius myth,
or you think that you're here for some kind of purpose,
then you should be, you know,
at the expense of community, friendship, love,
family relationships,
be investing all of your creative juices
into your work product while your brain
is capable of doing that.
You know, That makes me think two things.
First of all, Ernest Hemingway used to write
from like 5:00 AM to noon and was at the bar every day.
Right.
Every day.
Yeah.
So he figured.
Probably at the bar a little too much.
Again, leave a legacy.
Yeah. Well, and also all of that other stuff
was part of his writing.
Right.
Like he merged those two experiences.
But I do relate to that because I think
life is seasonal, right?
There's these seasons that you have
and I just look at it that way,
more of a continuum of seasons.
And it's like, I have another book I could add
to this pile in my car.
It's like a Buddhist kind of like everyday
read a passage type thing,
and one of them that really stuck with me
cause of the season I'm in
is that life is basically in seasons.
Sometimes you're gonna be free to go diving
with your homies every day,
and sometimes you have to sit in an office
and stare at your computer.
And then you have to be kind of committed to your family
and you have to, you're growing a kid and you're,
you know, you're watching him grow and enjoying that,
and there's just, there are restrictions on the seasonality
and within those restrictions and tensions,
genius comes through.
So when you have too much time and you're, you know,
so I think that I shouldn't have used the word genius,
but like moments of transcendence come through.
So there can be moments of transcendence
in the wide open escape
and there can be moments of transcendence
within this seasonal pressures that you're under,
and you can't access everything all at once.
Like, life is just not like that.
So the more we can embrace the conditions that we're in
is probably better.
And, you know, if that, I can't wait to watch this movie
because "In Bruges" is like
one of the best written movies of all time,
and it's the maybe the best written comedy I've seen,
in, you know, I don't know who knows how long, maybe ever.
And, but I love, I can't wait to see
how Brendan Gleeson and Colin Farrell go back and forth.
Whereas one buddy's decided, "No, I'm a musician now.
Go fuck yourself."
It's gonna be hilarious.
You know. (Rich laughing)
But I do understand that point.
Colin Farrell's just confusion over like
his buddy's sudden, you know, decision.
I understand the pulling back.
I've done it in different ways over the course of my life.
It's not always a great idea,
cause in the end, that interconnectedness exists
and we do need all these different kind of support systems.
So I can't wait to see how it plays out.
I just hope there's an evil Ray Fines in there.
(Adam laughing)
I don't know if he shows up.
Yeah. Not this time. Not this time.
Yeah.
Alright, well.
What do you think to that?
I have some more thoughts and it kind of dovetails
into turning 56 and, you know, having this birthday,
but let's take a quick break and we'll be back with some
more thoughts.
All right.
Prophets walk among us.
As a writer and podcaster for nearly 10 years,
I've become more convinced than ever that our world
is populated by scores of beautiful and brilliant people
who have amazing stories to share,
those that we don't know who can teach us something new
and leave us all the better for the experience
of their sharing,
and so I've dedicated my career to tracking down
the most compelling prophets on the planet,
going deep with each of them on my podcast
to elucidate the best of what they have to offer
and to sharing the insights gleaned for the benefit of all.
But the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories,
which is why I'm proud to announce the release
of my new book "Voicing Change: Volume Two."
More than mere words on paper,
"Voicing Change" is a physical manifestation of the magic,
inspiration, and timeless wisdom
that transpires each week on the Rich Roll podcast.
The first edition of Voicing Change
was a beautifully rendered book worthy of display
on any coffee table, and volume two
follows in that tradition by showcasing even more
of my favorite conversations in an elegant publication
replete with interviews, excerpts, essays,
and stunning photography,
making for an exquisite companion to the first volume
or a satisfying standalone work.
Picking up this book allows you to revisit
the wisdom of your favorite everyday prophets
and physically interact with the life changing ideas
contained within "Voicing Change: Volume Two"
available now while supplies last for a limited time.
Order your copy today only @richroll.com.
And we're back.
I do wanna share one thing before we get into like,
sort of reflections on getting older and that is the.
(both laughing)
Welcome to the getting older podcast.
We're just gonna get grizzled and gray and like
Wait 'til you guys hear us.
Mash our teeth about the young people.
Yes. Yeah. You can hear a foot story coming up,
which is very exciting.
Speaking of exciting.
Yeah.
Should we talk about Fuzzbubble?
Fuzzbubble!
So Jason Cameolo,
longtime audio engineer slash producer
sitting right over there right now.
He's the heavy around here.
He came up in a band called Fuzz Bubble.
They had their moment of fame back
on MTV on P. Diddy's label.
Jason ended up, you know,
kind of moving in a different direction with his life
after that experience,
but Fuzzbubble is getting back together
and they are going on tour, which I'm super excited for.
And they got an album coming out.
When's the album coming out?
Yeah, where is the?
The 20th!
The 20th of November. Fuzzbubble's new record.
It's gonna be on Spotify, right?
Is it gonna be on Spotify and all that kind of stuff?
Yep. Everywhere. All the places.
All the stuff.
What's what's the album title called?
Cult Stars From Mars.
I love it.
I love that album title.
Excellent.
And you're gonna be playing Huntington New York
on November 19th?
Correct.
Any other shows or just that one show?
Oh, New York.
New York on the 18th.
18th. All right, cool.
So we'll link up.
All right. Thank you.
Very cool.
Thank you.
Never too late for the dream, bro.
Yeah.
No man. You gotta keep it going right?
You gotta do what you love.
Exactly.
So here we are. I turned 56.
That's fuckin' old no matter how you slice it.
Is that why you're wearing a, are you wearing a cardigan?
The gray is coming in hot.
Is that a cardigan?
Yes. Is this what older gentlemen wear.
I'm wearing kind like a cardigan-esque thing.
Yeah, a little bit. A little bit.
And it's had me kind of, you know,
reflecting on getting older.
That's old.
I don't. What?
You're like "That's old."
Yeah. It is old!
Like I'm closer to 60 now than I am to 50.
You are.
Like, that's fuckin' crazy. Right?
(Adam laughing)
And it's inescapable,
cause now when I look in the mirror
I'm like, "Damn that gray hair, it's all over the place now.
Are you kidding me? You look fabulous.
No, it's really coming in hot.
You know what though, you know what,
can I stop you right there?
Yeah.
From the chest down, Steve Martin.
Just pure Steve Martin from the chest down over here.
Just all white, you mean?
You're talking about you?
Just coming in.
Talking about you. Yeah. Okay. Yeah, all right.
Go on.
You got a lot of,
you have a lot of dark hair in your beard still.
My beard's basically entirely white.
I'm like Santa Claus.
I do feel,
I don't know what you're supposed to feel like at 56.
I do feel physically quite good.
I have a lot of energy
and I want to be able to channel that energy
in productive, positive, fun, community-building ways
while I can, you know.
I had a great time at this Formula One experience
and it was great to be around a lot of people
that was different for me.
Like I'm kind of this lone wolf guy
who just kind of does his own thing
and I'm having serious FOMO about the New York Marathon,
the New York City Marathon, which was yesterday.
We're recording this on Monday.
It was on Sunday.
Had tons of friends participating in that race.
I know you were in Malibu.
Yes.
And April ran the half marathon.
Congrats to April.
Yeah. Yeah. She.
Ted McDonald was down there as well.
Yeah, they both finished really fast.
Teddy was like 1:30 something and April was 1:43
and I couldn't do it.
I was signed up for that race
and because I'm also getting older,
I'm 50, I tore my post-tibial tendon in training
and it was like a slow unwinding of a rubber band
in the middle of my foot.
It felt like a cramp in the connective tissue
with that little (creaking sound), and I ran home,
it was like a mile and a half run home,
and I'm like, "That's not good"
and I waited like a week and finally went to the doctor,
had the MRI.
My foot's been fucked up for a long time,
so it was probably heading that way, but I couldn't do it.
So I'm like, I ended up getting PRP injections.
I'm gonna get some more.
Hopefully no surgery, but I couldn't run it,
so I know the feeling.
You know, you wish you, I wanted to be,
I wanted to do it man.
I was like, my body wanted to do it,
you know, I was there.
Yeah.
And I thought "I could run in these hiking boots."
No. That would not have been smart,
but I had the same feeling about New York City.
I wanted to run that race.
My back issues prevented me from training for it,
and then I had to kind of watch it on Instagram,
watching, you know, Alexi Pappas and Shalane Flanagan,
so many podcast guests, like Alexi Pappas, Shalane Flanagan,
Hella was there kind of covering it, and he did,
he like, I think the day or two before the marathon
was his 2000th day in a row of running on his run streak
and his shoe sponsor, Hoka, gifted him
with like this golden shoe, like a trophy.
That's awesome.
And he had a big group of people that he was running with.
Casey Neistat ran,
and so that's the latest podcast that just went up,
and Casey, we recorded that last summer.
Davey running 3:50.
Amazing.
He's not here today cause he's still in New York City.
Shout out to Davey.
William Gooch.
He came, he was out at the house, the other week.
Was he?
Yeah, he was in LA for a couple days and came out.
He's a stud.
Ose running 2:40. I mean, come on.
Ose told me that that was what he was hoping,
that that's what was his goal was 2:40,
but he felt like he has more to give
and he's like going to, it inspired him
to get after it even harder.
That's what he told me.
This guy is unbelievable.
Unbelievable.
And he blew up,
He had this big viral moment from being with the Seahawks.
Did you see that?
Well, no, I haven't, I didn't,
I haven't seen the Seahawks one yet,
and there's the Tampa Bay one too, right?
Well, the Seahawks one was huge.
So there's all this video of him,
it's Pete Carroll and he's with the Seahawks team
and he's, you know, doing what he does,
and he guesses like the security code
to one of the guys' phones.
So he like, I'm like, and these guys are like pissed,
they're like, they can't believe it, right?
And that video, like ESPN shared the video,
Barstool Sports shared it.
Amazing.
Like Dave Portnoy like wrote a blog post about it.
So like suddenly Ose was in a different like stratosphere
Yeah.
Of kind of recognizability,
and then, you know, just relentlessly like goes
from one thing to the next. Throws down a 2:40.
Yeah. Like it's nothing.
A casual 2:40.
Cas 2:40.
At the New York City Marathon.
Robbie Ballinger was there. Again, my boy.
Did they all run it?
Len Churchill. Des Linden was leading the race.
Like yeah. Like tons of people ran it,
and I was like "Fuck, I can't be there."
I didn't know Robbie ran it for some reason.
He showed up, yeah, with his wife and ran it with her.
Amazing.
So anyway, it looked like a lot of fun.
Incredible.
And I was like bummed, and I was like "Never again."
Like whatever I have to do to get my back correct,
to get back into it,
like I want to be there next year, for sure.
Dude, that's your goal?
Just to have fun.
Is that your fitness goal?
Like, not to like, I mean my goal is really to be
pain free and to be fit and solid enough
so that on any given day I can go out and run a marathon
or ride a century
or do a swim run or do something and just have fun with it.
Yeah.
Like, you know, not to be like rubber banding
in and out of shape and all that kind of stuff,
but just to be in like a constant state
of fitness, preparedness, and readiness.
Yeah.
To be able to go have fun experiences with other people.
Like that's a big goal of mine for the next year.
Yeah. I have the same goal as to like get more full body.
Goggins has ordered me into the gym,
and so to lift weights and just to get more,
he thinks that my problem was 100 mile months
three months in a row without,
like, I wasn't really, I'm just wonky,
cause it wasn't really ideal for me
and I should have topped out at 80 mile weeks
during that period.
I probably would've made it to the race day,
and just by doing that, by pushing a little harder
when I wasn't fully like balanced in my body,
like muscular wise.
So I've been ordered into the gym.
Good.
And so I've been doing that.
Me too.
I'm in the gym, too.
Good, good, good, good, good.
What about the pool?
Is the pool okay for your back or not really?
Is it the pushing off that's not so good?
I think it is, I haven't been swimming very much.
The flip turns I think are really the inhibitor there.
Yeah.
It's not the swimming itself, but I'm just trying,
I'm like, my focus really is the gym right now
to get as strong as and stable as possible.
For the same idea, right?
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. So we'll see how it goes.
We can trade months.
My money is on you buddy.
I wanna see the workout that he wrote up for you.
He hasn't written them up.
He's giving me ideas.
Specific workouts.
And I think I'm not ready for his workouts.
(both laughing)
Come on.
I think, I think
I know, I know.
How about 70.3, dude?
Yeah. So Kristian Bulmmenfelt snapping back
after Gustav clutching the Ironman World Championship
victory out from beneath him.
Yep.
Following week, Kristian says, "Yeah, watch this."
Pulls it right back.
I mean like what was it?
One week or two weeks?
Two weeks. Two weeks.
Was it two, I think it.
Two, three weeks.
Two weeks. Not three weeks.
Two weeks.
I think it must have been two weeks,
10 days, something like that?
But on their podcast with you,
there was a foreshadowing of this
because Gustav said to you that he,
it takes him a long time to recover,
whereas, and Kristian said that he can go
week to week to week and just keep grinding out these races.
Yeah. He like doesn't accumulate lactate.
Right. And so Gustav kind of, in two ways,
kind of tipped this off one way is that his focus
is now all the way on Paris,
so he wasn't even thinking about 70.3 anymore.
Right.
He seems to have, like "I hit 70.3.
I did Kona Iron Man, now I'm gonna get that gold medal"
and that's where he's at.
Yeah.
Whereas.
Well and they just did Bermuda,
I think it was yesterday.
Okay.
Which is short course Olympic distance,
and I think, I should be up to speed on this,
I didn't read up on it as much as I should,
but I think Gustav was top 10.
So to go from Ironman to Olympic distance
and be top 10 at the elite level without, you know,
any kind of training modification
in such a compressed period of time
like bodes well for Paris.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't know where Christian ended up in that race.
It just shows that, but like Kristian
you know, he's so hungry to,
he just wants race after race, and he lost
and so he wanted this win.
I just find it interesting how they,
on your podcast, they basically told us
Kristian recovers better.
He can race again two weeks after an Ironman
easier than Gustav and
Right. Well, but what's also another
added interesting wrinkle to that is that
I think Gustav is actually like,
has a higher kind of threshold,
so he technically should be faster,
but if it takes him longer to recover, how does that work?
Right.
I don't know, cause they're very different athletes.
It's a fascinating discussion between the three of you.
I loved it, and you know this, but this particular race,
I was watching it and Kristian had that late downhill push
leaving American Ben Kanute for the win.
On the women's side, on the women's side.
I mean, the women were almost as fast.
Like the men finished their bike ride with an average speed
of 28 miles per hour.
I think the women were like in the 26's.
I mean they are fast.
And Taylor Knibb, another American,
rising back up and winning,
you know, the Americans are rising back up
in this sport now.
Yeah.
We saw it at Kona, right, with the second place.
We see it here with the second place
on the men's side, and then two first place finishes
with women that were just not even thought of
as real contenders.
Yeah.
I mean, no one even, they were off the radar.
Not that they weren't contenders, but they
no, they just weren't talked about.
Right.
And so now the Americans are kind of rising back up
in the sport, so that's gotta be exciting.
I mean, I know people that you're friends with
must be really excited about that in this triathlon world.
It is cool. Yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, it is cool.
Yeah. There is a shift.
I think it's a new, like just this new generation
of really interesting athletes
Yeah.
Who, you know, are gonna be competing at the highest level
for many years to come.
Yeah. It's cool.
But from that, let's switch gears.
Yes.
I do want to touch briefly
on the 3,100 self-transcendence run.
Insane.
My favorite race.
Yes.
Where they run around a block in Queens
like 800 billion times.
Yes.
To accumulate 3,100 miles basically in 52 days or less.
It's essentially running 60 miles a day
until you've run ostensibly the distance
of going from one side of the United States to the other.
I had Sanjay Raul on the podcast a couple years ago.
He made a documentary about this race
called "Run and Become" "3,100: Run and Become."
You can find that on Prime video,
where you can listen to our podcast.
In that, it follows some athletes who
and their kind of life stories and why they do this thing.
One of which is this guy Ashprihanal,
Ashprihanal Aalto, who's won it a couple times,
and he came in second this year.
The interesting thing about this though,
that I wanted to draw attention to,
is that there was a Ukrainian and a Russian
who were running it
and Outside magazine wrote this article
about these two guys who are friends.
Yeah, Ben Pryor. Ben Pryor.
You know this guy right?
Ben Pryor is a Rich Roll listener
and he reached out to me,
a Rich Roll listener and he reached out to me,
and we've worked together.
He's done some research for me in the past,
and he wrote this beautiful piece on this.
Yeah.
Yeah. I loved it.
It's pretty cool.
You're gonna link to it, yeah?
Yeah. I'll link to it and you know,
the power of running to, you know, reach across boundaries
and but also create some level of unity
and a bond for peace.
And also within yourself finding more,
you know, like that's.
Well that's what the whole 3,100 thing
is all about, right?
Right.
It's this three shin moi search for self-transcendence.
And you can't solve the world world's problems
if you can't, you know, transcend your own problems.
And that same kind of thread runs through your podcast.
It runs through the Goggins book.
In both books, you know, like that's what makes it unique.
That's why people want kind of this nectar I think
because, you know, too,
it is something you have to continually look for
cause it does.
Otherwise you just get distant from it.
You don't, well, you never like transcend it completely.
No. Right.
It tends to snap back.
Yeah.
It's, and I can tell you for a fact
that that is, you know, my experience of life.
Yes. Life snaps back in your face.
The minute you think like,
oh, you've mastered something,
you will be rudely reminded that the work is never done.
Yes.
But beautiful man. Yeah.
So we'll link up that in the show notes.
We should touch base on this guy, Nedd Brockmann,
who ran across Australia.
Did you follow this story?
The 23 year old electrician?
Yeah. This guy is off the rails.
He ran from Perth to Bondi,
50 miles per day in 47 days,
covering nearly 2,500 miles,
and he was raising money for a homeless charity,
and he overcame like so many injuries,
and like he at one point was sleeping two hours a day.
I mean, it was amazing.
And he got this huge following
like Forrest Gump style, didn't he?
It's crazy because people run across America
all the time.
Right.
And like, I've had lots of those people on the podcast,
and you know, it is like small groups of people are there,
kind of, you know, good job, and, you know,
maybe they have friends and family
and a hundred people meet them at the beach
when they finish, or in New York City.
I mean, Hella had a nice crowd
Right.
to greet him when he completed his run.
This guy though, I mean,
throngs of thousands,
like if you go to his Instagram,
like he finishes in Bondi Beach,
like look at all these people.
If you're watching on YouTube,
I have his Instagram up right now.
It's Nedd Brockmann, two Ds and two N's. Brockmann.
Unbelievable crowds of people to cheer this guy on.
And this dude is like the most Aussie-Aussie
in the history of Aussie's.
Like he's got a mullet and like the way he talks
and the vernacular and the use of like Australian slang.
Like, I don't even know what this guy's talking about.
Right.
90% of the time.
Fast talker.
I'm planning on being in Australia in January.
I wonder if I can track this guy down.
You got to!
See if I can convince him to come on the podcast,
cause I would love to, you know, hear more about this dude.
And he's 23.
He has like positive energy.
People love him.
Yeah.
There's something really cool about it.
You're, he's not 56.
Mad respect. He's not 56.
I'm literally twice his age, Adam.
No, you're more than that.
Should I be bummed about that?
You're not literally twice his age.
That's right oh my God, that's undershooting it.
Like dramatically.
A lot.
Yes. Thank you.
I appreciate that.
On the subject of being excited about somebody
who did his own crazy thing,
this guy, I wanted to shout out this guy, Paul Minter,
who is a dude in the UK, who,
a military guy who lost 14 comrades to suicide,
more than he lost to combat.
He was a soldier, and he founded this mental health charity
called Head Up for the military
and developed this range of positive mindset techniques
and to kind of raise awareness for that,
he ran 5,000 miles of the United Kingdom,
like around the periphery, I believe,
the periphery of the United Kingdom,
to raise awareness and money for military mental health
for this retreat center that he's trying to build,
which is really cool.
Very cool.
So anyway, yeah, I went to Andrew Huberman's live show.
He sold out the Wiltern Theater.
Right!
It was great. Did his thing. It was unbelievable.
Got to commingle with all of his fans.
It was super fun.
That's another weird thing about this era.
Now it's, podcasters going on tour.
Professors are playing the Wiltern.
Yeah. A neuroscience professor could sell out
the Wiltern Theater and perform a neuroscience
two hour lecture to a group of people who are taking notes
and completely engaged with what he's doing.
Like when you feel pessimistic about the future,
like that is something that gives me hope.
I think it's cool.
Everything, everywhere, all at once.
What's the connection?
Isn't that, didn't that movie just come out
or something like?
It came out like a year ago, but I don't know what all.
All this good stuff and bad stuff's
all happening all at once.
Yeah.
I feel you. I feel you.
Yeah. All right, let's take one more break
and we're back with more.
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome,
but I wanna snag a moment to talk to you
about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is, most people I know actually already know
how to eat better and aspire to incorporate
more whole plants, more fruits, vegetables, seeds,
beans, and legumes into their daily routine.
Sadly, however, without the kitchen tools and support,
very few end up sticking with it.
So because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly,
and because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised, I'm proud to say,
is the PlantPower Meal Planner,
our affordable, all-in-one digital platform,
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of highly customizable,
super delicious, and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery,
and you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches
seven days a week and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up, visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now, for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off an annual membership
when you use the promo code RRHEALTH at checkout.
This is life changing stuff people.
For just $1.70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com promo code RRHEALTH
for $10 off an annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
All right. And we're back.
I don't wanna dip too deep into the culture wars,
but there is a certain issue that I think demands
our discussion and our redress.
You wanna launch into this, Adam?
It's a strange time to be a Jew.
Mm. That's a quote from this book.
One of several books. I will be.
Oh, Michael Chabon?
Michael Chabon, "The Yiddish Policeman's Union."
A great murder mystery.
I haven't read that one.
And it's always a strange time to be a Jew in that world,
which it is.
And it has been lately.
You know, we don't have to get too deep into it.
We all know what happened with Kanye or Ye.
Is it yay, yay?
Is it yay?
Ye?
He wanted to go DEFCON 3 on the Jews,
even though DEFCON 3 is kind of like in the between.
DEFCON 5 bad.
So DEFCON 3 is just a skull.
Right? It was weird that he chose DEFCON 3,
like either go all the way in or like deescalate.
Right. Right.
DEFCON 3, just move it up a little bit.
We're gonna incrementally increase.
Incremental.
Increase the threat.
You know, it worked because there were, 405,
banners over the 405, kind of saying Kanye was right,
and people honking, you know,
"Kanye's right about the Jews"
and people, a lot of people honking.
There were mailbox incidents in Brentwood
and Pacific Palisades where kind of antisemitic literature
was distributed.
Cars were vandalized with swastikas in Calabasas.
I know somebody who had that happen,
or I know a friend of a friend, excuse me.
Who lives in Calabasas who had a swastika
painted on their car?
Not painted, keyed.
Wow.
And that same message that was on those banners
over the 405 was projected on a football stadium
a week ago at the Florida-Georgia game in Jacksonville,
a hundred thousand or so people there,
and the universities, both Florida and Georgia,
had to issue statements kind of obviously
saying "It wasn't us, it wasn't an organized thing,
and we condemn this."
And then kind of like, not too long after,
I mean, right after that, you know,
not too long after, Kyrie made his post
where he was promoting a movie that's on Amazon,
and you can find the movie,
I'm not gonna go spend that time on this platform
to talk about it,
but I will just say that it was a very antisemitic,
and it basically is a Holocaust denying movie,
among other things, and it talks more in like
the overall global conspiracy kind of jargon,
just like Kanye was getting at.
And that is, you know, that Jews run the world
and they're pulling a fast one or whatever it is,
and those same kind of ideas have been around
for a long, long time in neo-Nazi circles.
They've been.
All of these tropes
Yes.
That are resurfacing are age old and timeless.
Like they're the same arguments that get resurfaced
whenever antisemitism flares up.
A hundred percent. A hundred percent.
And so then there was like, after Kyrie's thing,
there wasn't, like some people spoke up,
but it took a long time, like days passed.
And yes, the owner of the Nets, who's Kyrie's team
that he plays on, the Brooklyn Nets,
said something right away.
And then there was this kind of lull
and nobody said anything.
The NBA didn't condemn it, didn't suspend him.
Nothing happened until,
I give full credit to Charles Barkley and Shaquille O'Neal
and Reggie Miller, Malibu's own,
who on their, on Inside the NBA,
and while they were doing their games last week,
they just spoke out very strongly against Kyrie
and in support of Jewish people, and so that was cool.
I mean, even after the Kanye stuff,
there was support on Instagram of people speaking out.
Yeah.
So there was.
A pretty pretty universal denouncement of Kanye.
Yeah. So there was a universal denouncement of Kanye.
Then the Kyrie thing happened, there was almost nothing.
And then that happened.
And so this, it is a strange time.
You're seeing the kind of, the antisemitism,
you're seeing the support at the same time.
Strange times to be a Jew.
But through all of that, in the defense of,
and in the denunciation of,
I noticed that people don't really fully understand
what antisemitism is or what these tropes are about.
And you know, I don't actually think,
I mean, I could be wrong. I don't think Kyrie is,
I don't think Kyrie probably even watched the movie
to be honest with you,
and I don't think Kyrie hates Jewish people.
I think he's gullible.
He's a flat earther guy, maybe years ago,
and so I think he, and I think even people
who defended Jewish people don't fully understand it.
And so I just wanted to take just a couple minutes
to talk about what I, how I view it,
and that is that Jewish, Judaism is not just a religion.
That's why people like to frame it, you know,
"I didn't mean to insult your religion."
It's not really just a religion.
It's a tribe of people that have existed
without a country for almost their entire existence.
Right?
You know, kicked out of Israel in Egypt, to slaves,
trying to get back to Israel, kicked outta there again,
end up in Eastern Europe, mostly, but all over the world.
My family came from, on my father's side, from Russia,
on my mother's side, Lavia and Poland,
and they lived their life here.
They came over in the end of the 19th century,
beginning of the 20th century,
depending on which side,
mostly beginning of the 20th century.
And when they were here,
Jews weren't considered white people.
And, you know, it was the influx of Jews
that actually ramped down immigration laws.
So all of a sudden, the wide open immigration
wasn't wide open anymore
because of so many Jews and Italian people,
but mostly Jews, that were coming in.
And so they weren't, so this idea that it's just a religion
is where I just wanna point that out.
That's just not correct in my opinion,
it's an ethnic minority group with a shared history,
and it's been under attack, not just on the right wing.
We all know that Charlottesville chanting
"Jews will not replace us."
But on the left, like I consider what Kanye and Kyrie
are doing is more on the left side of things.
Kanye is probably on the right,
but Kyrie more on the left side of things,
where there has been an increase in antisemitism,
quite frankly, straight up,
and a lot of that is conflated with legitimate criticism
of Israeli policy in Palestine,
but some of it is not.
And you'll see, you'll hear the same New World Order
kind of like, you know, "George Soros is evil" shit,
which is the same thing that they used to say
back in the early 20th century about the Rothchilds.
The same shit is being reproduced now
that you'll hear that in yoga studios.
Yeah.
I mean, you will,
and so you'll hear that on the left a lot.
And so what we need to do is
we need to combat this ignorance.
Obviously, it's always ignorance.
Any sort of prejudice is just ignorance.
It's just displaying your own ignorance.
We know that.
And so I would just encourage people
who are not familiar with Jews,
and there's not that many of us, you know,
a lot of people are not friendly with us.
So not just, not for any reason, just they haven't met us,
and so I would con,
there's a great documentary out right now,
it's a series by Ken Burns.
We all know how great Ken Burns is.
It's "US and the Holocaust"
and it dates back to how American Jim Crow policies
actually influenced the Nazi regime.
And then it doubles back and talks about how, you know,
early industrialists like Henry Ford were actually
in line with the Nazi regime and all of that.
But then it gets into real heroism and people who supported
and spoke out against what was happening.
You'd be surprised to know that like when the,
finally, during early days of World War II,
when it came out that a million or so Jews had been
exterminated in Europe, that wasn't front front page news.
It was like on page eight,
because I don't know why, you'll see in this documentary,
it wasn't front page news.
The only paper in the country that had it as front page news
was a Pittsburgh newspaper.
I think it was the Pittsburgh Courier.
It's a Black community newspaper,
and they were the only ones that put it on the cover.
And so, and that's because they had their own
intimate experience with like, oppression
and a genocidal kind of background.
Yeah.
And so I just,
I think that it's important that people watch that.
I think it's a great primer.
And I think, you know,
the only way to kind of eradicate this ignorance
is by shining a light on it and trying
to get to know a bit more about the subject.
I think if you haven't read it, obviously,
"Diary of Ann Frank"
Ann Frank's family stories in that series.
"Man's Search for Meaning" is like
right up the alley of this podcast.
Sure. Sure.
Viktor Frankl was in Auschwitz.
And this is a story of survival,
but also of trying to find, you know,
humanity in that situation.
And then there's Elie Wiesel who is,
this is a very dark story about his experience
in the Holocaust.
So those are great books I highly recommend.
But if your thing is watching video and watching movies,
Ken Burns is the gold standard.
Obviously we know that it's riveting stuff
and I highly recommend it.
Yeah. Cool.
Thank you for that.
It is so strange and disconcerting that there is this,
you know, this weird ground swell.
Yeah.
Right now of this sentiment percolating up. Like why now?
What is going on?
And what's so strange about antisemitism is the weird
and disturbing ways in which it kind of
prods both left-leaning and, and right-leaning people.
Like on the one hand it's the ethnic minority who's,
you know, who's penetrating our border
and like taking our jobs and you know,
you're the non-white people, right?
But on the other hand, it's also the people who have like,
sort of ingratiated themselves into culture and ascended to
positions of power and are secretly controlling everything,
you know?
Right, right.
So it's like both of those things are
Both of those things are true. Right.
At the same time, you know?
Right, right. And that's what fascism is, right.
When the right and the left meet, that's why it's scary.
But I'm not here to say that I feel like we're on that trip
down that memory lane to that dark place.
I don't think we are. I don't believe that at all.
But, you know, like, listen, I've had an,
I've experienced antisemitism my whole life.
It just happens, you know, like my great uncles,
my grandparents, they endured it on the streets.
I've had so many just like comments at me
or around me my whole life, it's fine.
We are not really geared to vocally fight it.
We're more geared to ignore it and just get on with it.
And that is, and that, like, if you look at Goldman Sachs,
I'm not telling you that I think Goldman Sachs
is a great institution,
but Goldman Sachs was started by Jews who couldn't get jobs
on Wall Street because they were Jewish.
And so then they started Goldman Sachs..
Started their own thing.
And like, look what happened.
You know, Hollywood started by Jewish people.
So these kinds of businesses,
I think that's where these myths and these conspiracies
come through.
You know, they didn't need Wall Street
to build Goldman Sachs and then dominated Wall Street.
So that's going to engender a certain jealousy.
I just think that, you know, obviously Kyrie made a mistake.
I think Kanye is having mental health issues, personally,
not an excuse for that behavior,
and I'm not here to excuse it,
but it just shows that we all have work to do, I guess.
Yeah. I mean, I am encouraged by the, essentially,
you know, broadly unanimous denouncement of all of this,
but there are pockets of people for whom you know,
that Kanye, you know,
Kanye's messaging like resonates with them.
Yes.
Which is disturbing, right?
And you can't separate that
from the impact of social media and the internet
on how it's shaping and warping brains alike. Right?
Yes.
In terms of like, you know,
what we're seeing spillover into real world ramifications
and culture, which brings us, of course,
to Elon Musk buying Twitter. It's very controversial.
Yes. Yes.
He's sort of this, you know,
incredibly successful serial entrepreneur,
richest man on the planet, who is kind of turning into an
edge lord, like interested in like, you know,
basically being extremely online on Twitter.
Yeah.
And has purchased this platform where he reigns supreme.
And it would appear as of today's taping,
is kind of making the rules, you know, as he goes.
Now listen, I think Twitter has a lot of problems.
I think there's room for tremendous improvement.
I would like to see it turn into a healthy ecosystem
for global discussion.
Elon Musk seems intent on making lots of changes.
As of right now. I'm not exactly sanguine
about those changes, you know, being as positive
as I think we would all like,
and this seems to be evolving moment to moment as we.
Right. Didn't he, today it was something like.
Was this whole, like this hard line policy on like,
you can't impersonate anybody,
unless you declare that it's sarcasm.
Right.
But all of these accounts were turning their names
into Elon Musk, and then he's like banning them.
And it's like, it's weird right now.
Right?
Everything that's going on.
Because Sarcasms always funnier when you say it up front.
Right. But if Kathy Griffin is changing her profile name
to Elon Musk, we all know that it's sarcasm.
Right.
Does she need to declare that?
And then her account is suspended.
Like what is, maybe there's something good
about having a hard line policy of like,
nobody can impersonate anybody.
We'll see what happens here.
This seems to be changing literally hour to hour.
The latest I heard was that of all the people
that were fired,
now they're trying to bring a bunch of those people back.
Did you see Kevin Roose's kind of.
Well he's got this new podcast now called "Hard Fork"
with Casey Newton.
Right, right, right.
And they did a whole deep dive last week on it
and actually interviewed some Twitter employees
about what it's like, you know, their lived experience
of being there and kind of living through all of this.
Are you gonna fork over your eight bucks a month?
Is that even happening?
I don't. Yeah, I guess that's already a thing.
There's an update where people are doing that.
Are you doing it?
I have a hard time imagining doing it.
Like I have problems with this in that it seems like really
what you're getting out of it is
amplification of your tweets.
If you don't pay the eight bucks,
they've basically said they're suppressing your tweets
and nobody's gonna see them.
So is this a free speech thing?
That doesn't seen free speech-y.
Yeah, like I think there is a bot problem,
and I think verification is important,
and it would be nice if everybody was vetted
and you had to actually prove and establish
that you are who you are.
I think that would solve a lot of problems.
And I think there is friction when you say you have to pay,
suddenly a lot of these bots and bot farms are,
you know, gonna get weeded out,
but I'm not sure this is the best way of doing that.
But I'm not a computer scientist
nor a social media engineer.
Right.
I just know that this is a very unhealthy situation
right now and it feels very tempestuous at the moment.
My friend Reese Pacheco sent me a couple of,
he's in finance and he's working on a great project,
I should say,
about kind of trying to find climate solutions,
but in, you know, investing in climate solutions for profit,
and he sent me a couple of like, diatribes on this,
and one of 'em was like this new social network
that they're talking about.
I know Jack Dorsey has a, he's in beta.
Yes.
On a new thing.
And so, like.
I signed up for that beta just to see.
Did you? It's a good idea.
I mean, but what would, what will happen,
like all these people who are on Twitter who had like
hundreds of thousands of followers,
they're not gonna give a bunch,
like if they go to Mushroom or whatever it is,
they're gonna start at zero. Like.
Mastodon?
Mastodon's one of 'em.
Is that Dorsey's one?
No, no, no.
I don't know who owns Mastodon.
The Dorsey one, I forget what it's called,
but it's still, you know, it's still in beta.
Like, you just give your email or whatever.
It's been interesting to see Jack Dorsey clap back
on Elon a little bit also because.
He's gone both ways.
Because, well Jack, you know, wanted,
like Elon was the person that Jack really wanted
to inherit this to,
and he felt very strongly that Elon
could solve these problems.
Now it seems to be that there's a little bit
of friction between them. It's hard to tell.
The genius myth.
I mean, yeah, here we are again.
The genius myth. The genius myth.
You know, here we are again.
Like yeah. So what is actually happening?
To me, it looks like a dumpster fire right now.
But maybe he can do this? I don't know.
Do what though? What is the,
what problem is he solving?
Good question.
Right? There's no problem to solve here.
Like the problem is that.
Well also we're going into the midterms right now.
Right
And like,
he's just fired staffs and teams of people
who are involved in content moderation
to avoid a lot of the misinformation that leads
to all of these problems that we're seeing with,
you know, alleged voter fraud, et cetera.
I would like it if Elon could figure out a way to get the
Democratic party to stop emailing me.
That would be good.
How many emails?
I could tell you, in the last two weeks,
I literally get dozens of text messages, phone calls,
and like, I spent, I have like a whole, like,
I spend hours every day reporting junk and like,
unsubscribing from emails,
but literally in the last five days.
Yeah, I mean like how many text messages are you getting?
Text message, email.
Phone calls.
And then they're all desperate and thirsty.
It's like, it's not, and like,
who's in charge of email strategy?
None of it seems like it's going well.
It's not good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like "We're gonna lose!"
Yeah, with this attitude, you're definitely going to lose.
Yeah, yeah. Yeah. One campaign.
So come Tuesday, tomorrow
at least all of that will stop.
Hopefully.
One campaign emailed me 14 times within a 24 hour period.
I told April, I said "This campaign emailed 14 times"
and she looked at me, she goes, "You're gonna lose, bro."
That was her message for that campaign.
"You are not winning."
Oh man. All right.
I mean, all right.
Let's crawl out of this.
Let's crawl out.
Desperate black hole.
Yes.
I do wanna note,
because we haven't done a Roll On in a while.
Yes.
And this might be the last roll on of the year because we go
into December. I've got some travel coming up,
I'm not gonna be around.
And then in December, we do our "Best of" episodes.
Unless you wanna do like a Zoom Roll On.
We can't do a Zoom roll on. Are you kidding me?
Trying to get, I'm trying to get another Roll On.
We might have to pre-record a Roll On
that we could release. We'll see.
All right.
But
I'm trying to one in, listeners.
There is a chance this might be the last Roll On
of the year, in which case.
I'm trying to get one more in.
Let's like bring it back to, you know,
something helpful to put.
Let's do it. Can I start?
Can I start?
Yeah.
Happy 10 year anniversary.
Thank you, sir.
10 years.
10 years to this week of this podcast.
To this date?
No, it's, I think it's kind of around Thanksgiving.
Okay.
Like, I think it's near the end of,
around the 23rd or something like that of November.
Can we turn this on guys?
Do we. Oh. Yeah. So I, we.
Before we do that. So we are celebrating 10 years.
We did, the last Roll On we did though,
I did do those 10 or 12 things
that I've learned from doing this for 10 years,
so I don't wanna completely reprise that,
cause that was a little bit of a, you know,
we were kind of celebrating then, but there was,
so when we first started, I'm gonna show this video.
We were early on the video because Julie and I
would record these little teasers about the pod.
So this must have been like for like episode four
or something like that. This is on YouTube.
Looking good.
Episode four on the podcast back with Julie Piatt.
So what did we talk about today?
Here's a little trailer video.
We're gonna tell you a little bit about what to expect in
this fourth episode of the podcast.
So we talked about crashing.
Rich crashed today. He's got a little road rash
Yeah, I crashed my bike today out here in Kauai.
So we talked a little bit about Cycling in Kauai,
which kind of brought us into talking about my Ultraman race
in 2009 cause I.
All right, I can't even, I can't watch myself any more.
We were talking about the, my crashing journey from.
Like earlier, I actually feel a little bit better.
Like, oh, I think I've,
maybe I've gotten better at this podcasting thing.
You have. You have.
But early on in video.
look how great you look!
Doing like, I looked, I was fit then.
Now I feel like motivated to get fit again
cause I am looking pretty fit there.
Anyway.
You look great.
You both do. It's great.
The point being it's been 10 years.
Look at you lovingly.
We're in this warehouse where the acoustics you could hear
are terrible.
I'm liking the, that fact that if there's a fire
that breaks out, you're gonna handle it.
You think so?
Well yeah. Look at the fire extinguisher.
Oh, there's fire extinguisher there and yeah.
Anyway, yeah,
it's crazy to look at that 10 years and of those kind of
lessons that I shared last time,
I felt like I rifled through them really quickly.
There were three that I kind of wanted to spend a little bit
more time on.
Okay.
The first of which, and the reason being
that I think this, that these lessons are applicable
and informative to anybody who's trying to achieve
or accomplish anything meaningful in their lives.
And the first one, and perhaps the most important
of all of them is consistency. Right?
Like, the reason this podcast is successful
is that over that 10 year period, we never missed a week.
We always uploaded,
we never succumbed to perfection paralysis.
Not every episode was amazing,
but we just had this mission of like,
hey, every Monday we upload no matter what.
And now we do, you know, a couple midweek kind of things.
But that whole,
like Monday morning there's a new podcast up every time
no matter what. We've never missed.
Professionalism.
The entire time.
So yeah. And so you learn as you go and you know,
as you can see from this video
and my cringe-worthy disposition,
they're not all gonna be perfect.
You're not gonna be great when you start.
And that's not the point.
The point is to marshal the courage to weather through that
and continue to keep iterating and doing in the face of
understanding that it's not gonna be amazing all the time.
Yeah.
And this is the case for you as a writer.
It's the case for me as an athlete or anything that I've
accomplished in my life as a result of doing small things
with extreme regularity and consistency.
That's how you move the needle.
So you look at these big goals and they're giant mountains
that you have to climb and there's something sexy about,
you know, planting your flag
and declaring that as your goal.
But in truth, whether or not you accomplish that goal
has everything to do with all the tiny little things
you do every single day when nobody's paying attention
and nobody cares,
and it's very easy to flake out and the stakes are low.
A hundred percent. You know, that's the case
of being a writer. You need to work the muscle.
It's a craft, it's not a talent.
You can have some talent and affinity for it
and some natural talent,
but that's not going to get you anywhere
in a professional way, in my opinion.
It could, if you also just happen to have like
built in tension, like you can focus
and get something amazing out,
then maybe yes, you can be a wonderkin.
But for people like me who did have some skill
but, you know, just couldn't, you know,
it took me a long time to actually be good.
And as a storyteller I could turn a phrase,
but to actually get good at this took me years and years
and years of frustration
and just make an appointment with yourself to go do it.
Even now I'm doing it.
Being willing to be bad. Like even if you like,
reduce the stakes even further in your daily journaling
practice or whatever it is that you're, you know,
trying to kind of master, doing it privately for yourself
and allowing yourself to be bad so that you get out of that
mindset of being stuck or thinking that everything you do
has to be great,
and I'm just thinking about like this next book that you did
with David Goggins.
Yes.
After like this just unprecedented success
of the first book.
Yes.
It would be very easy to be paralyzed and say,
"Well maybe we'll do a second book or maybe not.
Like, it'll never be as successful, so why do another book?
Let's go do a podcast or let's do something else" right?
Like let's not even try.
Right.
Or to go into that second book saying,
"Well there's no way it could be,
that was a flash in the pan, one time thing.
So okay, well, we'll do this book.
But like, you know, it doesn't have to be that good
cause it'll never be as good as the other thing."
But at least then we have like,
I can be of service to him and then we can and
obviously Jennifer Kish is involved deeply in this
and then it's like a team that.
Right, I'm saying the courage to do,
to show up anyway in light of like all of that
and then get to the other side of it
and actually create something that everybody feels
like rivals, if not altogether exceeds
the original book itself is a result of having the courage
to like not pay attention,
to not be paralyzed by that early success
Yeah. And that's, I think his secret to success in general
is he's always focused on the next thing.
The next thing.
Yeah. And he's keeping himself oriented forward.
And then when you have it, when it's a team thing,
it's a little even easier as a writer
to when it's a crew of us working together,
it actually doesn't make it easy.
It's still hard.
And he is, and he has his process, and I have my process.
And it's all writing, it's all one thing.
and but when you have each other and it's a team,
it's like even easier. When you're by yourself
and you're hitting your head against the screen.
It's a lot. It's harder to keep going sometimes.
Sure. And you don't have an accountability partner.
Cause it's just you and whatever fabricated deadline
you've come up with.
And nobody cares. Like, at least in that sense,
people were really wanted it, you know,
he's been asked about it, he's been like, you know,
and people really want it.
You know, there's a market for it.
So just like you said, yes,
the easy thing for him would've been like,
"Hey, I've made my impact.
I'll go do something else, cause I can do a million things
and the world's open."
And he chose this because he loves the process.
Right. Which brings me to the next thing.
Yeah.
Which is process over results.
Falling in love with the process.
Yeah.
It's okay to have a dream or a goal
that is oriented around a certain kind of result,
but if the result is all you care about
and the process is nothing but drudgery that you dread,
you're unlikely of being successful.
You have to find a way to engage with the process
and fall in love with it over time
to really allow it to energize you
rather than it be, you know, sort of an impediment,
you know, or something that you feel like
is an annoyance on the journey towards a certain result.
The more you're rooted in the process,
the less the results matter because to, you know,
sort of go back to the Goggins thing,
like whatever the result is,
you're onto the next thing anyway
because you're all about the process.
And well, when you're talking specifically about writing,
that is the process is rewriting and rewriting and
reanalyzing and reanalyzing and rereading and rewriting.
And so to get to be good at it, the process includes that.
So that liberates you from worrying about
is the first draft any good?
Now it doesn't necessarily always work that way
in everything that you're doing
when you're on a tight deadline,
but for me, almost anything I write the first time through
needs a lot of work.
I mean, that's just the way it is.
It's not your best work.
It's the first work and it's a way
to kind of get it out occasionally.
Like the O story, it came out real smooth the first time.
It's very rare that that happens for me.
Usually it, I chunk it out.
But the point is you're writing all the time
and we're using writing as a metaphor for anything,
that could be your race results or your, you know,
your grade in your college class or whatever it is.
Yeah.
But the point is, you're doing it
because this is what you do and this is who you are,
not because you wanna see a book on a bookshelf
in a bookstore, but because you are a writer
and writer's write.
Like, I think one of the great examples of this
is Ryan Holiday.
Like how many books has that guy written
in the last 10 years?
Like, he's written like
How old is he?
Twelve books and he's like 18 years old.
And the reason is that he is a writer
and he's in love with the process,
and as soon as he turns a manuscript in,
he's literally onto the next book like the next day.
Like he does not allow any kind of like interference
with the process of being a writer.
Like he's researching, he's making these cards,
and he goes through his whole process.
He has this box that he puts all his index cards in
and how he maps out all the
The nomicog system.
Like all the,
Yeah, and it's sort of, you know, when you're done
with the writing and then you're onto this
other phase of it, which is more reading oriented
and it's all detached from
whether the book ends up on some list
or how many copies it's sold.
It's the process itself.
It doesn't impact like what he wakes up and does
every single day.
Well, I respect that.
I mean, personally, I will say I think that sometimes
the process does feel like drudgery.
Sometimes it does for me.
Sure.
And that could be anything.
And I'm sure there's athletes that feel that way
about training.
But you do it anyway.
That's the point.
Yeah.
You do it anyway because eventually
there'll be a time in every session
where you'll find the reason you're doing it.
So like, even if it feels like shit,
you're feel like you're running in mud for, you know,
three, like for the most of your run,
for eight of 10k, there might be a point
where you feel like, "Okay, that's why I did it."
Might be right at the end.
Might be at the end with the endorphin rush.
Right.
But if, you know, for me,
that's an amazing story of Ryan.
Seth Godin is the same way.
I did a podcast with him. It hasn't gone up yet.
But you know, that guy's written a blog post
every single day for like how many years?
Right.
Back to 2005 or 2006
or something like that.
Every single day.
And he's a master of creative expression,
and you know, how you think about and pursue a life
as a creative person who literally, you know,
ships their work, like isn't paralyzed under the weight
of their own, you know, the pressures that they impose
upon themselves.
Yeah. Yep.
I mean, you know, you want to give your best effort
and sometimes it doesn't feel that way
when you look back at it that day,
but that doesn't matter cause it,
over time the process and the consistency is the effort.
Yeah. And that's what matters.
Right.
Really at the end of the day.
All the other stuff is nonsense,
because you do the thing because that's who you are
and this is what you do.
It's a great thing to remember.
Right. And it's back to
That mindset.
The final like point that I wanna make is around patience.
And you mentioned like, yeah, you show up for it,
you show up for it, it's drudgery, you hate it, it sucks,
it's terrible, and then you have that moment of breakthrough
where it's just flowing, right?
And you're this channel and it's all working out.
And you live for those moments as a writer, as an athlete,
where you feel in the flow,
as a musician who's writing a song, whatever it is,
those don't come easy and they're not predictable
and you can't manufacture them,
but the only way that you can experience them
is if you're showing up consistently
and make yourself available for that, right?
And that requires patience.
And beyond that, it's important to understand
that becoming good at anything takes much longer
than people are really willing to like,
reckon with or accept.
Everybody in this instant gratification culture,
they want the result,
they don't wanna endure the hard work
that it takes to get there,
and they completely overestimate what they can do
in short periods of time.
Like, "Oh, in a year I'll be here or whatever
I can, you know, this goal." And if they,
if things aren't going well initially right outta the gate
or it's not headed in the direction immediately that they
want it to head, people abandon their path.
And the truth is, and I beat this drum consistently
because I think it's so important
and I'm not sure that people really appreciate it
or believe it,
but it really does take at least 10 years
to get good at anything.
Whether you're an athlete, a writer, podcaster,
musician, like you show up for something every single day,
it's gonna take 10 years minimum
before you have any kind of like solid aptitude at that,
that is worth sharing with other people.
I found it interesting.
And again, going back to your interview
with the Bergen boys, that even when they were 14, like
They were trained like professionals.
Yeah. Gustav said he trained for 10 years,
and even at 14 they had a 10 year plan right?
At 14.
And now they're 10 years later and everyone's like,
"Oh my god, nobody can do this well at their first Kona"
and they're crushing it.
But Gustav was like,
"Yeah, I've been doing this since I was 14.
I've been training like a professional."
This is a 10 year plan finally manifesting.
So let me ask you,
have you ever had a five or 10 year plan?
No.
Like a formal one?
No. Not really.
No. Like.
I fall in love with certain things
and I get invested in them and I pursue them
and I've experienced that I actually don't get good at them
until like the decade, you know, lapses,
and I'm just feeling that now with podcasting.
As a swimmer, as an athlete, it took 10 years to,
I mean obviously I was a kid, you know,
growing into it and all of that.
You know, I've heard this when I was a lawyer,
"It takes 10 years to build a client list
and be successful."
You know, you as a writer, like, I don't know,
I mean certainly there's outlier examples.
Took me 20 years.
20 years. Yeah. Like and all,
but all of these experiences that you have inform the craft.
Well like Ryan Holiday, those guys sound very structured.
I've lived kind of an unstructured,
April always calls it, I lived the improv life
or that's how she always perceived it.
And now I'm getting to the point where I've already know my
ideas or have fielding ideas for next books right away.
Like I'm into something already.
And so I'm now getting to that point.
But I've never had the,
I remember an ex-girlfriend's aunt once asked me
my five year plan and I was like offended.
I was like, "I'm offended by that remark."
Yeah.
I was offended. So like.
Because no true free spirit artist
would have a five year plan.
Yes.
That is offensive.
A five year plan is like a mask to the anti-masker.
(both laughing)
That's what it was like to me.
I was like, I didn't want anything to do with that stuff.
Yes. I was more free spirited and all that.
And you know, I still have that within me.
So it's interesting to like ponder that.
Like I was wondering if you had it like even now,
now that you have a whole operation, do you guys have,
how far out do you guys plan?
It's interesting, like I don't have a five year plan,
I don't have a 10 year plan, but I do have,
the way I think about it is what gets me excited
and what am I curious about?
And I have the privilege and the freedom
to indulge in those things now because this is successful
and because I'm surrounded by talented people
who are very capable and can handle a lot of the things
that, you know, I used to do on my own.
And Tyler who's here back working with us,
used to handle for me when it was just the two of us.
Now I have some added free time to think about
and execute on other projects,
and that is a privilege and I don't take it lightly.
So I don't think about it in terms of five or 10 year plans.
I think about it in terms of like,
what would be cool, what would feel meaningful, you know,
to invest some extra time in?
Where do I feel under expressed and how can I express myself
better in a way that would be helpful to other people
outside of the podcast?
All of those things are things I think about.
You have your goals.
But I don't do it on.
You have, like towards like during the year,
you start to think about next year towards the end, right?
And think about is there something I want to add to the list
next year? I mean, do you do that at all in any,
even an informal way?
Maybe in a very informal way.
Okay.
Like I said at the outset,
like I want to have a stable body
and I want to be fit enough so that I could like pop into
all of these fun experiences.
Like that's a sort of vague goal, I suppose.
Yeah.
But important to me and meaningful.
That isn't wed to any kind of like timeline
or anything like that.
So I think setting goals is important.
You want to have a north star,
something that you're working towards,
but I think you also have to hold onto those a little bit
loosely, and I've said this before,
like be available and open to, you know,
other intervening miracles that can
reconfigure your trajectory, cause if you're so, like,
"This is what I'm doing!" and you're so rigid about it,
then perhaps you're also blind to other things
that could be beneficial or.
Right, right, right.
Really interesting.
I was looking at your early episodes and you had Julie
on episode one and three, had Chris Jaeb,
is that who you were collaborating over there right?
Yeah, he was the owner of Common Ground.
He was like our host or whatever.
And then you had Gabby Reese episode eight
and kind of you're off and running now on that train.
I mean I loved going through like, looking at that.
I'm like, it's really inspiring to look back
and see like that trajectory for me anyway.
It was cool to see.
Is there any early moments you remember that where you,
where it clicked for you?
Like any early stuff where you're like,
"Am I doing this? Am I not doing this?
Am I playing? Am I real?"
Is there, was there a moment early on?
Well there was never a sense that this was a vocation
or a business,
like it was literally like me having a creative impulse
and feeling a little bit stymied on this island
where I felt disconnected and uncertain
about what my next move would be.
And also as a fan of podcasting, interested in this medium,
and had for a long time wanted
to explore the possibilities there.
So I did the homework to figure out how you do it
because it's not self-evident how you do it.
It still isn't like you do have to like,
"Oh, how do you get this thing up on Apple?"
It wasn't Apple podcast then, it was iTunes.
How does that work? Blah blah blah.
Figuring all of that out and then just sitting down
and having a conversation with Julie,
at the end of which thinking
"That was fun. Let's do that again."
It wasn't like, "Oh, this is my new life" you know?
Right, right. Right, right.
It was just, now people launch podcasts
and they have strategies and they hire publicists
and they're pre-selling the advertising.
Yeah.
And they have a whole thing about like,
"How many should we record ahead of time?"
And what it was like, it wasn't like that at all.
Like we were just freewheeling it and having fun
and did it for a long time before we monetized it
in any meaningful way.
I mean, years before it was self-sustaining
in any material way, but doing it for the love of it,
doing it because I enjoyed the process of it,
because it scratched a, you know, a creative itch
and it allowed me to, you know, continue to grow
and explore, you know, new ideas by allowing me
to have conversations with interesting people
at a time when people were not clamoring to start podcasts.
Like it just wasn't a thing back then.
Like it was very unusual and not cool to have a podcast,
but I loved it.
And you know, now the fact that it's like
this huge kind of medium where there's so much energy
and interest in is like an added bonus, right?
It's very cool to have a now.
It's crazy cause it.
Now you're all at the red carpet.
It was literally the dorkiest thing ever.
Like, it was sort of like, "Do you work at Radio Shack?
Like "Well you're some kind of weird hobbyist" you know?
Yes, yes.
Embarrassing to admit, you know,
in mixed company that you were a podcast host
and obviously that that has changed and.
But you used to have to explain what a podcast is,
I'm sure.
Sure. Of course.
Yeah.
How many years before you monetized it?
I don't think, I mean, I think we did some ads
here and there for like Audible that were like,
we were barely getting paid anything.
So technically maybe we ran some ads, you know,
maybe in the second or third year.
But it had to be, I mean it,
four or five years into it before.
But it was helping the sale of the book.
So you were, you were getting seeing some revenue like
Right.
Yeah. But like the audience, it, it also,
it also was just very gradual growth,
like there was never any big viral moment like that.
So there was no moment you could point to and you're like,
"That's the moment where this plane really took off."
No, no, no.
It's just very, very gradual.
Consistency.
Consistency, dude.
Yeah.
You know,
everybody wants those big spikes, but you know, truly,
if you just keep showing up and keep showing up and refuse
to quit and continue to get better and devote yourself to
the thing that excites you and that you care about,
like you, you know, then you're available for the miracle,
and that doesn't mean that you're entitled to anything
or that anything is guaranteed to occur,
but it certainly can't occur if you bail on it
or you are unable to be consistent or show up for it
or give it the respect that, you know, it deserves.
Beautiful.
There you go.
Well thanks for inviting me into it in the.
Yeah man.
In the recent years.
Here's to 10 more years.
Yeah.
I still love it.
I really do.
It's.
And I'm excited for the,
for what's gonna happen next year, too.
We got lots of cool plans.
It's really exciting. It feels like more,
you're actually mainstreaming in a way.
There's people who I know that listen to this,
that have come to you in recent years
that aren't, I would never have put in one of your
kind of like, you know, you had one thing I always,
when I think about the success of the Rich Roll podcast,
you think of, well you have these niche markets
that were always kind of, you were organic kind of,
you belong to the sober living.
The plant based athlete.
The plant based and the endurance athlete.
So we've talked about that before,
but now you're getting people who aren't necessarily
involved in any of those.
You know, you're getting almost a million
on YouTube now?
Yeah.
I mean it's pretty amazing.
Almost a million subscribers on YouTube.
I know.
That's nuts.
It is nuts.
Yeah. I'm one of them.
Do you subscribe? You subscribe?
I'm a subscriber.
I'm glad you subscribed.
I'm subscribed to both
So do you get notifications and alerts
when you show up on the YouTube?
No, because I have an alert when my name
is on the internet.
I don't wanna see it so I have the opposite.
Okay.
Can I just point out one thing?
Yeah.
Before we get into listener questions?
Remember we talked about the murder
of Eliza Fletcher in Memphis?
I do.
And we talked about kind of the danger that women face
going out running and I mean at night especially,
and people asked, I think I got a couple messages,
"Are there any solutions?"
You know, I think we maybe got a phone call about that.
Yeah.
And we didn't have, we tried our best,
but we didn't really have anything.
Well this company called Nathan,
I'd never heard of them before in my life.
Yeah. They make lots of hydration vests
and camping gear and dance running gear.
They have put together this,
it's a night running hydration vest
that includes a siren,
like a high volume, high decibel siren,
that you can pull a rip cord on
and it will just explode with light and siren.
Wow.
If you're in any trouble whatsoever,
that'll wake up the neighborhood.
So it would be very hard to visualize someone hearing that
and not running far, far, far, far away.
Yeah, that's great. That is an amazing solution.
Yeah, it's a solution.
So Nathan, you're saying they're reputable, you know them.
I'm sure they are. It's a great piece of equipment.
It's certain, and you know, if you added
like a little pepper spray canister in one of these pockets,
then you'd be fully loaded, I think too, and feel better.
And it has hydration.
Yeah.
And it's reflective gear for running at night.
Exactly.
So it's firing on all cylinders.
All cylinders.
So congrats and Nathan, thanks for putting this together.
I think women can really benefit from it, don't you think?
Yeah, that's a good idea.
Yeah. Cool. Okay.
Alright, let's go to some listener questions.
Listener questions.
Okay, here we go.
Antonia, in Petaluma.
Hey Rich and Adam.
I'm Antonia calling from Petaluma in Sonoma wine country
and over the past two or three years,
I've been experiencing this increasingly persistent call
to write a book. You know, it's not fiction, not a memoir,
but a book about a specific recurring theme in my life.
So my question to you is, how does a lay woman like me,
I have a business degree,
I'm a winemaker and a yoga instructor,
with zero English lit or creative writing background,
go about writing a book?
Where do I even start?
I would like to write it myself and find a good editor,
but have no idea how to go about that.
I realize this is a rather broad question,
but since you both have written successful books
with varying degrees of previous experience,
I'd really appreciate just a couple of nuggets
of your wisdom. Thank you so much.
I love this question. Thank you Antonia in Petaluma.
Yeah, Petaluma. Great town.
Thank you, Antonia.
Listen, the answer to your question,
like how do you begin, how do, where do I even start?
You start by starting.
You have to get outta your head and outside of like
all the baggage that's holding you back,
all this storytelling, this narrative about
how I don't know how to do it
and I don't have a background in English and all of that.
Just get out of your own way with all of these BS reasons
and get out a pen and a piece of paper
or open up your laptop and start typing.
It feels like you want to know where it's gonna lead you
or you want to have all of your questions resolved
and answered before you begin,
and that's just not how it works.
The way it works is universe conspires to support you when
you put in the work and you show up for it.
So begin by doing that,
and something inside of you will come to life
because you have this thing inside of you
that's yearning to be expressed,
and it's actually, here's a way to kind of reframe it.
I think it's actually an act of violence against yourself
to not express it.
Hmm.
By repressing it,
you are not in loving kindness to who you are.
Clearly you have something inside of you that's nagging you
to be brought to life and every day that goes by
or you ignore it or you repress it,
or you look for an excuse to not actualize it,
is not in service to who you are.
It is not in service to your authentic self
that is telling you that you need to get this
outside of yourself, and all the stuff you're worried about
will get answered and resolved.
There are people out there who can edit books,
who can help you with structure, who can fact check,
and you know, there's a lot of amazing books out there
that are not by people who have some background
in English literature.
They're from people who have something to say.
That's the most important thing when you're writing a book.
I never took a creative writing class.
Do you, yeah, do you have something to say?
The English part is easy.
Like that has almost nothing to do with it.
There are other people you can bring in to fix all of that
kind of nonsense, but the having something to say,
like really having something to say,
that is the rare part and that is the hard part.
So remember that and just get into action.
Begin. Make it a practice,
and make that practice non-negotiable.
Create structure around that practice
and then protect that structure above everything else.
Get it done. Ship the work.
As Seth Godin would say.
Ship the work.
None of it is meaningful until you ship it,
which is when you let go
and you allow it to be in the world.
Yes.
Right?
Which is scary in its own right.
We want to protect it.
It's not perfect yet. Gotta hold onto it.
Once I let go of it, I can't control it anymore.
I can't iterate on it.
There's a sense of vulnerability that comes with shipping it
and you don't have to experience that fear or that
vulnerability as long as you are continuing to tinker.
Right?
I've been tinkering with a novel a long time.
I'm getting ready, I'm getting closer to shipping,
but I'm still tinkering.
Yeah.
It's hard. It's scary, cause I've never,
I've never, haven't had success in the novels,
in the fiction space, so it's like terrifying.
Right. But you have written books,
so how does all of this square with you?
Like what would you say to Antonia?
Well, I would say, I'm gonna give some practical feedback.
I mean, you have some interesting books
that you recommend for her to kind of take a look at.
Yeah.
Steven Pressfield.
You talk about Rick Rubin's new one,
"The Creative Act" I think.
Right. Well let me just do that
and then I'll turn it over to you.
Yeah.
I mean, you know, I've done many podcast episodes
on the subject of kind of getting out of your own way
and getting into the creative flow.
Brian Koppelman is fantastic on this.
So search the archive for that one.
We talk a lot about the practice of journaling
and the importance that Julia Cameron's book
"The Artist Way" has played in his writing career.
That book has been instrumental in my life.
It's a book that I continue to return to, to this day.
I've been doing "The Artist's Way" on and off since 1996.
Yeah. Since 1996.
Stephen Pressfield, his book "The War of Art"
and he has a couple other books in that vein,
"Turning Pro" et cetera.
I did a podcast with Steven, but his book "The War of Art"
perhaps the best book to read on getting out of your head
and getting things onto the page.
Seth Godin, again, I did a podcast with him,
it's not out yet, but he has a book called "The Practice"
which you should check out,
similar to "The War of Art."
Rick Rubin's book "The Creative Act"
is coming out in January.
That book is fucking awesome.
I'm gonna buy hundreds of copies of that book
and give it to everybody I know.
Really?
It's really a beautiful book.
It's a book that anybody who is interested in creative
expression, whether you're a writer or whatever it is
that you're trying to manifest in the world,
I think would benefit from reading.
And I would add to that list, Chase Jarvis's book
"Creative Calling."
Chase is also a friend of the podcast
that's been on the show before.
So in terms of resources, I would suggest, Antonia,
that you check out all of those and then
I would add "Big Magic."
Put those aside and start. Oh, "Big Magic" also.
Great.
Yeah. By Elizabeth Gilbert.
Yeah. There's a little bit of "Big Magic" energy
in "The Creative Act" in Rick Rubin's book
and the podcast that I did with him that's gonna come out
in the new year. We talk about that a little bit.
But yeah. Great, great addition.
Yeah, I like "Big Magic."
The problem is, and then I'll turn it over you.
Sorry to keep speaking over you.
No, no, no. Not at all.
It's easy to then get immersed in all of these books
and podcasts and say,
"Well, I'm learning about being creative"
when actually you're just using that as a,
like a smoke shield to prevent you
from actually doing the thing.
Yeah. I think that's a great point. I mean, personally,
I am not one of those writers that really meditates
on the practice of the creative,
or on the creative process at all.
I never have been. I've been much more, you know,
just do it kind of like the consistency,
just put in the hours and do it.
But from the practical aspect of this, I think you're right,
in terms of doing some preparation,
reading on it would be helpful to her,
cause it would decode it.
And then I also think that, you know,
getting into some sort of journaling practice
or just a practice would be helpful
because you don't have the muscle built up yet
and you need to get it, you need to get it working.
So having said that,
when you're talking about actual practicalities
of how does a book come to this world,
in nonfiction you have the ability to write a book proposal.
You don't have to write the whole book.
You can write a sample chapter or two,
figure out the marketing plan,
figure out where this book fits in the marketplace,
and all of, you can easily Google book proposals
and find some examples.
And that's how, I don't know what the full percentage is,
but a vast majority of nonfiction books are sold today,
is they're sold via agents to publishers
in book proposal format.
And so you don't actually have to write the whole book
to get to create a book,
and eventually you do, but you don't have to get.
But those are two, like yeah, it's a good distinction
to bring up. I guess the question is,
what is the purpose of this book?
Is it to just write a book and be expressed in that
in that thing that you're trying to, you know,
wrap your head around or is it to be a published author?
Like that's a whole different thing,
cause you're bringing commerce into this.
Right, right, right.
And so I guess I was just putting that in
because it's the only thing I could add
that's more a little practical,
when you're thinking about this,
and obviously she's visualizing a book.
Right.
A product.
And there's many ways of like,
you can self-publish, you can do the book proposal thing.
You can.
You know, the book proposal thing is now
it's sort of like, you know how studios
are only making superhero movies,
Right?
Like now publishers are only making books from,
you know, people with giant Instagram accounts.
That's true.
You know, it's like a lot of that kind of stuff
gets played into it,
but none of that should be an impediment
to you creating the book that you want to create,
because we're in an era in which those gatekeepers
no longer are playing the role that they once did,
and there is no impediment to distribution.
You can create a self-published book
and get it on Amazon and get it out in the world,
and perhaps that's the best first way
for you to become an author.
Yeah, I love it.
We're moving right on to Rich, not Rich Roll,
but Rich in Rockfield.
Rockford.
Oh.
Rock, Rockford.
Rich in Rockford.
Hello Rich and Adam.
This is Rich Toffee from Rockford, Illinois.
I'm 71 years old,
so I suspect I skew toward the older range
of your listeners.
I discovered your podcast about five years ago
and enjoy the great interviews and information.
Roll On is especially a treat when you share your banter.
It's like hanging out with a couple of good friends.
I've learned a lot too.
I can now say, "Hey, it's not age slowing me down.
I'm just doing a lot of zone two training."
My question comes from listening to both of you
so effectively share your reading experiences.
Clearly, you both read volumes of information
to be your best as an interviewer and a writer.
How do you retain and then retrieve as much as you do?
Certainly you prepare for specific topics and guests,
but you often pull thoughts from books you've read long ago
and then apply the ideas to a subject
that has randomly popped up.
I love to read, but wish I could retain much more than I do.
Are you just lucky enough to have superlative memories
or are there some skills that you could share
to help us all get more from our reading?
I really appreciate all I've been getting from your program.
So all the best from the Midwest.
Thanks a lot. Bye.
What do you think, Adam?
I just think that he sounds like a swell fella.
Sounds like a nice gentleman.
I know. It's like the Midwest, his Midwest,
his, you know, you know what I mean?
Like his manners and his.
Congenial and convivial.
Yes. That's what I think.
Yeah.
I don't think I have a great memory.
I definitely, I assure you,
my memory is anything but superlative.
Yes, yes.
But you are good. I mean, he's right.
You are good at pulling, you know, tidbits of knowledge
and things that you remember from either from your past
or things you've read.
Especially I think in your one-on-one guest stuff.
Yeah. Nice. It's nice that he has pointed that out.
Yeah.
I would not have thought that I was somebody
who would stand out in any way for that.
I mean, I think to the extent that that is true,
and I would challenge just how true it is,
it's because this job requires homework.
You're always doing homework,
and a lot of the guests that I've had on the show
are published authors, and I do my very best
to read their books in their entirety,
or at least as much as I possibly can
before they're on the show,
and if they have multiple books,
to familiarize myself with the cannon of their work.
And I spend probably eight to 10 hours of prep per guest,
irrespective of whether they're an author or not,
and I create an outline for each guest.
So that forces me to take what I've read and distill it down
into interesting kind of bullet points.
I don't write out questions, but I write topic headings,
and if it's somebody, if, you know,
if somebody's written like a non-fiction book,
I'll kind of go through the structure of that book
and extract from that themes and principles
that I want to explore with the guest.
And I think the process of not just writing,
but then creating the outline, you know,
every little extra step cements the information
and the knowledge contained in the book
a little bit more deeply,
and then I'll review the outline and I'll refine the outline
and then I'll make extra notes.
So all of those little things, I think really help,
you know, anchor whatever I've learned in the memory bank.
And I don't know how long it stays.
Like, you know, sometimes I don't remember anything
about what we talked about or what that book said.
For books that are super meaningful to me,
it seems easy for them to remain in my conscious awareness.
Other books not so much.
And I think it goes to understanding how you learn.
Everybody learns differently.
Like I know that often,
I'll consume a book as an audio book,
I'll go out on a Saturday morning for a long bike ride
and I'll listen to half of an audio book,
but hearing it, I don't retain it nearly as well
as I do do when I read it.
Like I'm a visual learner.
Is that, that's right.
So then I have to
Interesting
Go to the printed book and
kind of go through it and make notes and in the typing
and in the, looking at my computer or in, you know,
the pieces of paper,
like something about my visual cortex or whatever
gets activated that helps me learn better than hearing,
and I'm sure other people are the other way around.
So I think it's a piece of self understanding
and then developing practices to kind of cement
what's important for you to learn.
And now there are all of these resources,
you could read a book.
I know what it's like to read a book
kind of casually and then be like, "I have no idea.
I can't remember anything from that book."
Right, right.
But you can go to Blinkist
or you can find summaries online
and just doing little refreshers
brings a lot of that stuff back.
And it's helpful because it's easy to read
like a really long book
and you've read so much
that you lose the forest for the trees, right,
and you kind of need a synopsis or a summary
to like remind you, "Oh, here's what's important.
Here are the primary tiers
and here's the kind of scaffolding upon which to hang
all of these interesting ideas."
And revisiting that, I think with some regularity,
helps kind of, again, with that long term memory piece
of really anchoring it.
And then thinking about it and like how does it apply to
your life also in terms of problem solving?
Yeah.
At least in the kind of non-fiction space.
That's interesting.
I don't think I have great memory or can pull
pieces of writing or like, I'm not the guy that toasts,
you know, and recites.
I'm terrible at reciting
Recited Chaucer.
Yeah.
Or you have friends,
they remember quotes from movies and they can, like,
they remember everything about what a movie was about.
Right.
That they saw 15 years ago. I'm definitely not that guy.
And I can, I do it even, I can,
I have a better memory for movies sometimes than books.
But there are, and there's times when I'm writing a story
and I'm like deep diving into material
and I'm reading a lot about it, and then I'm,
I write this piece and then as soon as it's done
and it's published, if you ask me about it
like three weeks later,
I would sound like it wasn't me that wrote it.
You know, like, I also have that where it just
kind of goes away.
I have that with the podcast.
People are like, "Remember when you know, you and so
and so said that thing?"
Right.
"And you talked about that thing?"
I was like, "No, I have no, I have no memory of that."
Yeah. But I write, I read,
I read as much as I ever did, maybe more.
So I'm putting books away a lot quicker.
I've got, I'm reading fiction and non-fiction
simultaneously now.
I used to stick with a book
and I'd finish it no matter what.
So that would block me from reading more books,
cause sometimes I'd be in a book that's dry
or that I'm not connecting to and I'm.
Just cause you started a book
doesn't mean you have to finish it.
Right.
So now I give myself permission to not finish it.
And so because of that I'm reading more
and I'm kind of, I am going back between fiction
and nonfiction.
I used to think "When I'm writing nonfiction,
I'm gonna read fiction.
When I'm writing fiction I'm gonna read non-fiction"
and I just don't have those kinds of guardrails
at all anymore. They're just excuses.
And to be quite honest,
there's so much content out there, TV content
and like audio content, there's so much of it,
I find myself like taking up shelter in books,
you know, like I can't take that.
How can you read a book though
when White Lotus is back, Adam?
Well I'm on White Lotus, I'm on that,
but you know what I mean, it's like,
and so I'm reading more than ever.
And so, and some books do stay with you, right,
for long ways.
And so often I think if you're saying that I brought it up,
it's probably cause I brought, I bring up the same
like five books. But I do, I will,
one recommendation is Dwight Garner,
who is a literary critic at New York Times.
We've talked about him on this podcast I think before,
and he has something called Garner's Quotations
that just came out not too long ago, maybe a year ago,
and he is one of those that can pull a quote for anything,
like he can pull a quote outta left field for any occasion.
His own quotes or just quotes of things
that other people have said?
No like stellar quotes from like luminaries.
And then another person, Kelton Reid,
who has The Writer Files, a podcast host,
a good friend of mine, he does the same thing.
He's able to put quotes out there
and you'll see it on his Instagram or The Writer Files.
And so they're really good at that.
I think I'm just,
I just read as much as I can and hope to retain it,
but I don't have any strategies for you.
Yeah. So you didn't answer his question at all?
(both laughing)
I have no strategies.
I can't.
Keep reading, read more.
All right.
But I appreciate the question.
Yeah, it's nice.
I think he's talking to you. You're good at that.
You are good at that.
It's nice that you appreciate the question.
Listen man, you're good at that.
You happen to be good at it. You.
Yeah. But it's sort of like, there's a little bit of,
you know, like you cramming for a test?
Yeah.
You know, so you know it all.
So I'm like fully
Right, right, right, right.
Fully dialed when I'm doing the podcast.
Like how long does that remain?
Also when you get older,
like the hard drive's full dude, you know,
like everything that comes in something else has, like,
I'll notice like I can't quite like,
we couldn't remember Brendan Gleason's name.
No.
Right?
Like that's a name that like maybe 10 years ago
I would've had no problem recalling
because the hard drive is kind of, it's cramped, right?
It's dusty.
Yeah. You gotta like, if I'm taking in some bullshit,
I gotta get rid of something else.
Right. That's why take in less, read more.
I have one for you though.
One last thing that we could offer.
Cause you know,
I know you talk about David Epstein's book range.
I do talk, that's one that lives with me.
That kind of fits here,
because like I think that we both have
wide interests and because of that we're going to read from
wide, you know, range of material,
and so it might seem like we're like, we know more,
you know, that idea of having a range of interests
might feed into this in a way.
Like you have memories from different parts of your
kind of personality or the dashboard that you're seeing
the world through, and so that might help actually
kind of being sounding like you have a little bit more
handle on things than you really do.
Right. It's all about like the illusion
of making it seem like I'm better at stuff
than I actually am.
Great.
There you go.
This is good. I hope this is revealing.
Yeah, let's get this last question.
Let's get outta here.
Let's land this plane.
Yeah. We're going to Zach up in, I dunno,
is he in Spokane? He's in Eastern Washington.
Eastern Washington.
Hey Rich and Adam.
My name is Zach Smith. I'm from Eastern Washington.
I'm around 27 years old and I'm a plant-based runner
studying to become a dietician,
both things inspired by your podcast.
Currently I am training for the Mesa Marathon
and the good news is with that zone two approach,
I am getting faster, but I'm actually becoming scared of
achieving my goal of qualifying for Boston.
I feel like I'm getting hooked on getting faster as a runner
and losing touch with the broader joy of the sport
at only three years into my running journey.
So I was hoping to hear you and Adam speak
to why we pull ourselves away from family and friends
to pursue these efforts and how motivations
for these efforts change across time,
and if you have any past podcast guests who speak to this
that you'd recommend returning to, I'd love to hear them.
Thank you for your time.
That's cool. Yeah.
Thank you for the question, Zach.
To the point or to the question of speaking
to why we pull ourselves away from family and friends
to pursue these efforts and how motivations
for these efforts change across time.
I don't know what you're talking about Zach.
I can't, I wouldn't, that doesn't happen. I never do that.
Right. But I don't know what is animating Zach?
Like, I don't know what his motivation is.
Is it, it sounds like it's germinating from some kind of
performance goal that he has qualifying for Boston,
et cetera.
I think it's interesting that he has enough self-awareness
to realize he's getting hooked
on the performance aspect of it,
and this is draining some of the joy out of the sport
at only three years into this journey,
and that self-awareness is powerful
to the extent that you channel it into some kind of
behavior modification.
So I think, in your case, there's some easy fixes.
Understanding that you have this goal,
you wanna qualify for Boston,
but you're also afraid because you're getting so into the
performance piece that it's not as fun as it used to be
or it's not, it's not as joyous as when you began.
So let's cure that by incorporating
into your training routine some fun runs
where you don't have the garment on,
you take off the heart rate monitor,
you forget about the log or whatever, you know,
sort of purpose of the training is that day
and you just go get lost in the woods
or you go out with friends and you have a good time.
The joy is the sustainable energy
that will keep you in the sport, you know,
for many years to come,
but if you lose touch with that,
you will burn out and you may achieve your goal
and all of that, but that goal won't be as joyous
or as meaningful as it could be if you're able to find a way
to maintain connection with whatever it is about running
that provided that sense of joy to begin with.
That's a great answer, cause I know Davey talked about it
before going to New York that he wants to take a break from
running after New York and April said the same thing.
She had this goal of sub-1:45 for the half marathon
and she is like the same thing.
It's like "I'm ready to stop running for a while."
And so interesting, and they, I'm sure they both were on
these training programs and they were on
performance kind of based.
Your life gets very regimented.
Right. So that's, I love that idea,
cause you know, the other day I went for,
I hadn't been able to get out cause I've been working
and just can't run, and I went out for a swim
and I forgot my Garmin at home,
and it was my most fun swim I've had in so long.
Right. At first you're like, you feel naked,
like, "Does this even count? Did I even do it?"
Right, right, right.
You know, which is weird.
And it's my furthest swim I've done in the ocean
since, you know, I did the 5K swim a couple years ago,
so it's like maybe three years ago.
So it was great.
And so that's a great piece of advice.
I think, in terms of pulling yourself away
from family and friends, I wouldn't put like,
I mean you're 27, I wouldn't put that guilt on you,
or maybe you're feeling a little FOMO
because you got a lot of young people and friends
that are like having a lot of fun at night
and you have to get some sleep cause you're running
early in the morning.
Maybe that's where that's coming from.
I personally think that we are called to escape.
Like, and it's okay. Like I think the beauty of escape
is a wonderful thing I've lived many times.
As a Jew, it's in our nature.
But no, but all seriousness,
like the idea of dropping out and going for a long travel
or getting out in the ocean and forgetting everything
for two hours or going for a long run,
I think there's a lot to be said for that.
So I wouldn't feel bad about that, pulling yourself away.
It's what I do now is kind of take bite size moments
like that if I can.
It's the only time I'm not either working or spending time
kind of help, you know, with the family and all that.
We need that, especially Americans
and the individualist society that we are in.
I find myself needing that time
and it's the best way for me to take time
that's also fueling my wellbeing,
which only helps me work harder
and be better with my family.
So all that kind of stuff, I don't look at it
as pulling myself away,
I look at it as needed time to recharge.
And so that's the only thing I would say to the question
that I disagree with, but I think your point
to like bringing the joy back is really cool.
Yeah. I mean I think rather than framing it
as an escape versus being plugged in, think of it as
nourishment versus depletion.
Like are you being nourished by these training sessions
or are they depleting you?
If you're training for a hardcore goal,
you're gonna get depleted,
like you're gonna be pushed and challenged and that's okay.
That's part of the whole deal, right?
And there's something to be gleaned and learned
about yourself from that experience,
and this is part of why we sign up to do hard things.
Yeah.
But ultimately in the long run,
it has to be more nourishing than depleting,
and whether that means you take breaks
or you find ways to build into whatever it is
that you're pursuing, that nourishment piece,
be it through community or through a relaxation
of the pressure that you're putting on yourself, et cetera,
getting immersed in nature or just finding a way
to make it fun, gamifying it somehow, that's critical,
even if you might, in the micro,
feel like it's moving you away from the goal
that you're seeking because it's not
part of the training program.
Right. Right, right, right.
Ultimately it's going to, you know,
build longevity by creating that, you know,
deeper kind of emotional connection with this thing.
And your motivations for these efforts change.
It's gonna change. You're gonna evolve, you're gonna grow,
you're gonna have different responsibilities
and desires as they come through.
It's like we said earlier, this seasonal aspect of living.
That's just the way it is. And so we embrace that,
We embrace that these motivations are going to change,
that we're gonna try to find a new way to approach the same
thing that's been good for us,
and that's the goal.
But then if you have to kind of press pause,
there's nothing wrong with that either, right?
Like, if you need to take, look at it as a season,
maybe look at how, you know,
tennis players take six weeks off at the end of the year,
or runners take four weeks off.
Maybe you need to take a break so that you can come back
fresh and there's nothing wrong with that.
Yeah. And finally, to kind of round this out,
the part of the question was whether there's a past podcast
guest who speaks to this,
I would suggest my conversation with Brad Stulberg
and his book "The Practice of Groundedness."
Brad's pretty great on this very subject matter.
He's also a great follow on Twitter where he writes,
he sort of micro blogs on Twitter,
and talks a lot about this kind of thing.
He's great. I've got him on Instagram now, I believe.
There you go.
Yeah. Yeah.
Right. Yeah.
But did you see Kipchoge recommended two books
you recommended?
He recommended "Atomic Habits" by James Clear.
Okay.
Friend of the Pod.
Yes.
And he recommended Brad Stulberg's
"Practice of Groundedness."
Oh really?
How about that?
What a cool. Like it's one thing like James Clear sold,
I don't know, 10 million books.
Right?
I mean that book is crazy.
Oh my God.
Right.
But for Brad,
like, very cool for him.
It's very cool.
That the GOAT is like, "Read this book."
Did he run, did Kipchoge run,
or was he just on the outskirts of the race?
Did he run the race?
You mean ever? Does he just float above the road
when he runs?
Did he run in New York?
In New York? No.
Okay.
No. He did a shakeout run though. I know Davey did.
Right. Cause I knew he was there.
So I didn't know if he was running the race or not.
No, I don't think he ran the race.
Okay.
Yeah. Cool.
All right, let's get outta here. Are we done?
Yeah, dude.
We're done and.
How do you feel?
I feel still 50.
Do you still feel 56?
I feel 56. What does that mean?
How am I supposed to feel at 56?
I don't know man. All I know is I had a PRP injection.
Have you had one of those?
I had that for my back on one occasion.
I mean, that is, that hurts like a motherfucker, dude.
It's no joke. It's no joke.
My eyes were watering for like three hours.
I thought I was gonna go back and get some work done.
I was literally on the couch trying to read
with like eyes watering. Pretty funny.
Yeah. Tales from, tales from the fifth
Tales from the fifth decade.
From the fifth decade. All right.
Listen, if you have a question you want us to talk about
and who knows when we're gonna do a Roll On again,
but anyway, leave as a message. The number to do that.
Wait, are you firing me?
No. I don't know when we're doing Roll On's again.
What is this? Is this Twitter?
You're not? No. Yes.
All hands on deck.
(both laughing)
You might get fired,
but you could get called back into work next week.
I'm gonna fire you, but I'm gonna call you, yeah,
and plead with you to come back.
Yeah.
Leave us a voicemail at 424-235-4626.
And that's it. Any parting thoughts?
No, that was, Thank you.
Thank you for the time today.
Yeah. Thank you.
Super fun. Let's do it. Should we do it again?
That was fun.
Let's do it one more time.
Yeah.
Before the end of the year.
What do you think people?
Maybe we'll see.
All right. Peace.
Let's.
Namaste.
(mellow transition music)